what is the nature of reality this is
essentially what we're showing is that
our thought processes are changing our
reality in the future that's through
just very well accepted behavioral
perceptual and physiological mechanisms
and all this is showing is that
sometimes the effects can add up and be
really profound
today we talk about the placebo effect
mind over matter and the cognitive traps
that correlate with IQ David Robson is
an author of science with a unique focus
on human intellect and behavior he has a
degree of mathematics from Oxford we
both Bond over our similar degrees in
mathematics except of course he's
actually done something productive with
his he's worked for new scientists BBC
and he writes for several popular
science magazines today we discussed the
intelligence trap and the expectation
effect my name is Kurt J Mongol I have a
background in mathematical physics this
podcast is called theories of everything
is dedicated to the exploration of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as exploring the role Consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of nature
each sponsor as well as the patrons
improves the quality of the videos
drastically it improves the depth it
improves the frequency and it goes
toward paying the staff for instance
someone who is editing this full time
right now and then we have an operations
manager in that vein I want to thank
today's sponsor brilliant if you're
familiar with toe you're familiar with
Brilliance but for those who don't know
Brilliance is a place where you go to
learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marleto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point how also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order if you'd like to
support the theories of everything
podcast and help assist that is the
improved video quality the depth the
frequency of the podcast and paying the
staff then do consider going to
patreon.com Kurt J mungle the link is on
screen as well as in the description
there's a custom amount as well as
already delineated tiers either way your
viewership is thank you enough thank you
and enjoy this interview with David
Robson David thanks for coming out I
appreciate it I've been listening and
reading your book for about it was
months ago and then intermittently in
the past few weeks so thank you it's an
honor to speak with you
what got you interested in intelligence
yeah I mean that's something I was
interested in since I was you know quite
a young child
um because in the UK we have this kind
of streamed school system
um no it's only kind of in my area in
the southeast of England but we
um take this exam called the 11 plus
um that decides which type of senior
school we go to
um and essentially it's an IQ test by
any other name and if you score in the
top 25 percent you um go to a grammar
school which is meant to be for kind of
academically gifted children the rest go
to a comprehensive school so I took the
exam I did quite well you know got into
my senior school but I was just kind of
a bit baffled by what this test was
really measuring because it wasn't the
version that I took you know really
wasn't looking at what I'd learned at
school previously it was all of these
you know verbal non-verbal questions
that um didn't seem to be directly
related to kind of education
um such as and so I just wondered you
know it was kind of word association
things there were the kind of mental
rotation exercises all of these things
that I later learned you know a kind of
standard IQ questions
um so they seemed quite narrow and I
guess I was always interested in like
what's it mean to be intelligent what
and you know what is that measuring how
kind of generalizable can it be and then
when I became a science journalist like
I became super interested in this
phenomenon because
um you know I was interviewing some of
the world's greatest Minds you know
people who you know changed our
understanding of the universe and you
kind of just had to look a little bit
more deeply into their private lives to
realize that while they were obviously
showing High Intelligence in their
particular field and they could also be
um like surprisingly stupid and there
really is another word for it and other
areas of their life so you know there
was this guy Kerry Mullis who developed
the polymerase Chain Reaction which we
use for all kinds of genetic testing and
you know it's the PCR test that we use
for covid
um but he was a climate change denier he
was in HIV denier he um even believed
you know that he'd traveled in the
astral plane that had met this kind of
glowing raccoon in the forest of
California you know had some very
strange beliefs that just didn't seem to
be scientific let alone the kind of um
kind of thinking that we would expect
from a Nobel Prize winner he won the
Nobel Prize for chemistry for the PCR
test
um so you know it was really that they
kind of led me back to this kind of old
childhood fascination with intelligence
and I just wanted to understand like
what do we mean by intelligence what
does the IQ test measure and what does
it Miss and what are the other kind of
mental traits
now what are the elemental traits that
we should be kind of cultivating and
appreciating that aren't measured in
kind of standard academic tests what do
intelligence tests measure and what is
intelligence yeah I mean so the the idea
had been that you know we have this kind
of generalized intelligence and this
goes right back to the early 20th
century
um which is like a kind of underlying
brain power
um it's kind of almost like the kind of
processing capability of the brain
um and actually you know we know that IQ
tests do measure something meaningful
and that they may be reflecting some
kind of anatomical difference in the
brain that does reflect a kind of
General processing ability because we
know that even those you know very
narrow abstract tasks that I described
that I took in my childhood IQ test well
you know people's performance on that
does seem to predict their academic
achievement and then also how well
they're doing and their different
professions and especially kind of
professions that need kind of Greater
um you know classically kind of
intellectual inputs of things like law
Medicine Science you know um so if we
have a high IQ we probably are quicker
to learn kind of complex stuff quicker
to understand complex stuff
um
so you know it's useful I would I don't
want to kind of
uh you know downplay the the kind of
relevance of IQ but the fact is that we
also know that it's by no means the only
thing that's important about someone's
intellectual abilities
um so you know even if you're looking at
those kind of classic professions you
know I only
um kind of can explain the a kind of
minority of the variants in people's
performance you know so there's lots
more to IQ even if you're a lawyer or a
scientist or a
um a doctor you know it's not going to
make you incredibly creative for example
so we know that it's missing something
important and then what I really wanted
to look at in the intelligence trap was
just well like what is it missing and
how does it relate to things like
rationality and wisdom and you know kind
of how we navigate all of the complex
challenges that we face in life that
aren't just based on a kind of academic
test of knowledge and learning in the
book something that stood out to me was
that there are a variety of cognitive
biases and there are some that people
who have a high IQ are more prone to can
you talk about those
yeah I mean totally so it's quite
complex I should expect
um that you know a nuanced as well
um but essentially like scientists have
been looking at these kind of cognitive
biases that have been studied by people
like Daniel Kahneman since you know the
1970s and we know you know humans act
kind of irrationally in lots of
different situations and to just give
one example we suffer from this
um thing called the sunk cost fallacy
where you know if you're
um pouring resources into a project like
we feel very reluctant to abandon that
project even when we realize virtually
any gains we're going to get from
continuing are only going to kind of um
they're not going to pay off they're
only going to lead us to a further loss
um you know but the famous example of
that is would be
um Concord project in the UK and France
it was like taking like heaps of money
from both governments um it was never
going to be profitable but once they'd
started the governments just couldn't
face kind of cutting off the project so
they they continued even though it was
always going to be a loss is the Vietnam
War an example of that as well yeah that
kind of thing would absolutely be an
example yeah yeah yeah where and it's
just really difficult to kind of um cut
your losses and I'd set defeat um even
even when you know that you're never
gonna win yeah
um and so you know the uh we've known
that exists for like decades but what
the new research had shown
um research on what's known as the
rationality quotient had actually shown
us that people were you know High IQs
compared to low IQs are really no more
or less susceptible to that you know
being super intelligent does not make
you more rational in that case
um so that's one example where
surprisingly intelligence doesn't make
you kind of more logical
um but then there are other phenomena
where actually High Intelligence can
even make you more irrational
um and that is when it gets to kind of
justifying your bad decisions so if you
have a really deeply funded belief in
something you know it might be like
Arthur Conan Doyle the author of this
Sherlock Holmes novels um they believe
in the Paranormal uh well what we know
there is that then the more intelligent
you are actually the more kind of uh
resilient you are to any contradictory
information so your intelligence
actually protects your beliefs and
prevents you from looking at the the
evidence that might actually lead you to
a more rational point of view and we saw
that beautifully with Arthur Conan Doyle
in all of his writing you know he's
actually drawing on all of his
creativity and his scientific knowledge
to try to justify some really crazy
beliefs um so for example he he believed
in fairies he bought the Beast young
girls in Yorkshire in the UK who had
taken photographs of berries kind of
around the Babbling Brook at the end of
their garden and um you know other
Skeptics around him you know pointed out
things like um that you could kind of
see there were cardboard cutouts stuck
together with pins
um he said well actually I'll you know
let the pins are stuck in the middle of
well those marks in the photos us only
appear in the middle of the fairies
bellies so he took it as evidence that
it was
um a belly button and and it was a sign
of the umbilical cord so he actually
used that contradictory evidence to then
make this weird inference that varies
are born
um in the same way that humans are with
an umbilical cord and then he drawn
these theories of electromagnetism like
Maxwell's new theories to explain why
normally we couldn't see fairies with
the naked eye
um so he was actually using his
knowledge there to justify this very
strange belief that all of the people
around him who may have been less
intelligent just couldn't actually
believe but it's almost like his
intelligence was fueling this rational
belief because it was so Central to him
and you look into his biography and you
kind of see that he uh was mourning at
the loss of his son and so the belief in
this kind of spirit realm actually
became really important to him
personally because he wanted to believe
that you know there was an afterlife
that he would be able to see his son
again but then he was actually you know
rather than helping him to deal with
that grief you know these beliefs were
just causing him to pour you know fast
some persons of pounds into kind of
supporting these fraudulent mediums and
to you know he ruined his reputation
amongst his peers by kind of
um supporting all of these beliefs so it
really backfired for him and that was
for me a very clear example of how
intelligence can can kind of lead us
astray it can actually drive us along
the wrong path in life if we don't have
kind of checks and balances to make sure
that we're applying it correctly
do you make an equivalence between
irrationality and illogicalness
illogicality
yeah I mean I do think they're very
related and essentially you know when to
talk about irrationality I'm kind of
trying to say when
it's all of those cases where where
not making the optimum decision based on
the information in front of us and you
know anyone can make a mistake if you
don't have any sufficient information
um but you know in someone like African
and Doyle's case you know there was
enough information available even if we
didn't have all the scientific knowledge
we have today there was enough to
suggest that these beliefs in the
Paranormal were very irrational but um
and you know a bunch of people around
him were skeptical but he wasn't so
that's you know that's what I mean by
rationality
um but rationality could affect things
like financial decision making you know
causing you to pay too much but
um a property or to make a better
investment you know it could be in all
kinds of areas but it's essentially when
you're making the a less Optimum
decision
um despite evidence that should should
have helped you to make a better
decision
it does rationality incorporate
healthiness into it so what I mean is
that it's rational to make a decision or
to have your goal as something that's
salutary in the long run
whereas logical as just following a
sequence of steps like modus opponents
and so on like axioms I think that's a
great way of looking at it you know
logic I think could be restricted more
to you know like a very specific kind of
question
um but like I do think when we're
talking about irrational when we're
talking about rationality and
irrationality we are really thinking
about you know how do we make decisions
that align with our long-term goals and
in making the kind of optimum life for
ourselves the reason I ask that is then
could there not be the argument that Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle was doing what's
rational because it provided him comfort
and so some of these false beliefs let's
just say false in a scientific sense or
factual sense and that's putting a huge
asterisk because we don't know the
answers to large questions but let's
just put a pin in there for now that
belief in quote unquote factually false
ideas can be rational because they're
adaptive
um yeah I mean that's not the kind of
definition of rationality I would take
because I feel like
so say you know I feel like oh yeah it's
true Arthur Conan Doyle kind of wanted
to have that emotional Comfort but I
think if you asked him
would you be willing to believe in these
things even if they were proven to be
untrue he would have valued truth above
emotional Comfort like I'm certain
looking at his writings that he really
wanted to believe the truth and felt
like he was spreading the truth for
other people
um so it's all about the kind of
alignment of his goals but I really
think he did actually value rationality
and we can see that in Sherlock Holmes
The Character himself is like a the
epitome of rationality so I think like
if yeah like I just think in that case
it's like he would have rather had a
rational belief than a comforting belief
like a true belief than a comforting
belief that he was still drawn to this
comforting belief because
um
yeah because I I guess he couldn't
somehow couldn't resist it yeah but I
agree like I think it you know
definitions of rationality depend on
what you value in life but you know
scientists and psychologists in
particular talk about epistemic
rationality and that's really where you
value truth and you're always looking
for truth and then if that is your goal
and you're then believing something that
is not supported by the evidence then is
a rational in an epistemic sense and
that's absolutely what Arthur Conan
Doyle the suffering approach let's give
philosophical for a moment would valuing
the truth even if it led you to a
deleterious outcome be rational so let's
say I value the truth I want to know how
potent can this virus get so I'm going
to make a virus or make Ebola and cross
that with whatever is extremely virulent
because I'm interested in the truth but
yet that has the potential of destroying
the entire world or let me investigate
an even more potent bomb than the
hydrogen bomb that's a truthful Endeavor
a scientific truthful one my question is
just because something is truthful or
factually the case does pursuing it mean
that you're irrational or can there be
something irrational about pursuing the
truth like should you value truth about
what's nourishing yeah yeah it corrects
you're not flying too close to the Sun
you know
um is is it always good to push kind of
human understanding that far
um
now I would say that's kind of whether
you pursue that or not you know
isn't to me a question of rationality
um because say
so for some of these questions I think
it's perfectly rational for you to say I
don't know and to have that humility you
can just be you know like you can say
and it's totally factually correct and
epistemically correct to be like we
don't know how dangerous this virus
could become or we don't know how potent
that bomb can become and we don't want
to pursue that because the risk is too
great for our other goals which is the
survival of humanity so in that sense I
think it's you know more rational really
to say we don't know
um and we don't want to know we don't
want to take that risk so it's not
always just pursuing the truth above all
else but it's more also than accepting
like uh calibrating you know your
beliefs about that particular phenomenon
and saying you don't know is a perfectly
reasonable rational response to
something
um what would be irrational would be for
you to make some claim that the bomb
isn't is or isn't this dangerous or that
the virus is is or isn't this dangerous
based on a lack of information
um so yeah that's why I stand on that I
certainly don't think we should have a
Relentless Pursuit for truth over all
else but um but I do think we just have
to be honest about where the current
level of evidence stands okay while
we're on this I want to get to the
growth mindset and then a fixed mindset
but also as you steel manned what IQ is
earlier I want you to steal man the
dangers of an open mind only because
we're constantly talking about that we
need more openness and as someone who
has been exploring an unjudiciously
exploring theories of everything let's
say I've been privy to the more heinous
aspects of an open mind and I mean that
in a psychological sense what I'm saying
is that the case for the more ruinous
aspects of an open mind are rarely made
at least by intellectuals because
they're constantly saying we need to
have more of an open mind more of an
open mind so I'm curious for you to
steal man
what it's like to have too much of an
open mind how do we know when we're too
open
um interesting I mean given the examples
the gay black Lovecraft quotes it makes
me think of
um you know Plato's idea of the people
kind of in the cave looking at the
shadows and one of the prisoners escapes
he you know goes he sees the fire he
sees what's beyond the fire and you know
he sees the beautiful reality but it's
like how can he persuade the other
prisoners that they want to see reality
rather than sticking to what they know
um and you know so yeah I think this is
a question that we've had for Millennia
on kind of
and how far do we probe like
um how much can we how can we deal with
like a new kind of Truth
um so I'd absolutely think that is an
open question
um you know I think the a great example
which I'm sure you've covered in this
series is you know what if we discovered
that we didn't have free will you know
what kinds of consequences would that
help for kind of human behavior and
actually there are scientific studies
that have tried to manipulate people's
beliefs in Free Will or um like a free
will and you know it does have important
consequences for things like our moral
Behavior you know our kind of sort of
discipline like if we don't believe we
have free will we really struggle to
kind of motivate ourselves to do
anything because you just feel like you
know what's the point Your Fate has
already determined
um so you know I do think like we could
come to a stage where we do come to some
conclusion about kind of consciousness
of the origins of the universe where we
we have to wrestle with with these um
these issues and we do have to know
whether you know how close to the Sun
we're gonna fly and if we're like Icarus
um yeah I don't really have an answer
but that I mean my hunch at the moment
is that we're so far away from that but
as a society we should be trying to kind
of pursue you know as much knowledge as
we can provided that it is you know with
it um kind of conducted in a safe way so
you know we don't want to kind of create
that deadly virus
um unless we can be certain that
while studying it you know it won't leak
from a lab you know that kind of thing
like we have to have all these kind of
measures in place we even a small
possibility of a disaster
um I don't think it's worth it because
you know eventually you have enough of
those kinds of near misses of one time
is going to
um backfire and you could face a real
catastrophe so you know I think like
that's why we have so many like
regulations and rules in science and you
know they don't always work perfectly we
should always be improving them but I do
think we need to kind of temper what we
do and always make sure that it doesn't
kind of bring about risks
um but in general yeah I don't think
we're kind of close to that kind of
um that kind of issue I think separately
there's a question of the individual
like you know can it be just too
overwhelming for an individual who is
like so relentlessly curious that
they're almost overwhelmed by what
they're discovering and I think that's
also something to bear in mind you know
I think you know I think curiosity is
something that brings so many benefits
and I write about that in the
intelligence trap you know how like
curiosity you know it literally makes
you smarter and that it makes you learn
more quickly it makes you more rational
because you find it easier to balance
kind of information that might be
contradictory you know you're kind of
looking but the uh you're you're willing
to accept like um evidence that
challenges you which is really important
for being rational so you're not
suffering from confirmation bias
um so I had always thought that we
should like cultivate curiosity but I
think if you get to a point where you're
actually just struggling then maybe you
know you also have to slow down a bit or
take your time you know manage like how
you're dealing with that Curiosity
making sure that you're not kind of
pursuing too much
um too quickly at any one time so I
guess that's where I stand on that is
that um even though you know
open-mindedness curiosity you know
they're great traits we always have to
kind of rain them in and make sure that
like um they're working to our advantage
and that you know we're not going too
quickly about thinking about the
consequences whether that's personal
where but that's for society can you
talk about some of the benefits of
curiosity and then also I'm going to ask
you about how does one temper their
curiosity if they're much like myself or
I feel like it's not producing positive
effects always
right so curiosity you know it's this
kind of hunger for knowledge and we know
that you know neurologically speaking
when you feel curiosity like some
amazing things happen in the brain so it
actually triggers the release of
dopamine which we think of as being like
you know a neurotransmitter associated
with pleasure and it might be why
finding out new things is you know is
fun but actually dopamine also
strengthens um the storage of memories
that kind of cements the memory for you
so it actually improves your long-term
memory of what you're learning and then
there's this kind of amazing kind of
spillover like Halo of things so if
you're curious about something you know
in a kind of physics class or you know
when you're reading a book like it
actually helps you to learn not just
that one fact but to actually
strengthens your memories for all of the
other facts that surround it so you know
in education making sure that someone is
curious and that they can pursue their
curiosity it's really beneficial it can
actually help to kind of um
uh you know like erase or blur the
differences that arise from differences
in IQ and learning if someone's really
curious then really dedicated you know
that's as good as having a higher IQ
essentially even if the IQ is closer to
average so we know it's it's important
in learning and memory and then we also
know that Curiosity can help to offset
some of the
um kind of biases that can sometimes
come with greater intelligence so I
mentioned earlier that people like
Arthur Conan Doyle suffer from this
thing called the my side bias and that
is and motivated reasoning which is
where you you're attached to a
particular Viewpoint and then you only
search for the evidence that supports
that Viewpoint and you like use your
intelligence to dismiss any arguments
that might contradict your point of view
um which can lead you down some kind of
wormholes where you're believing
something that you know most other
people consider to be purely irrational
and you know it's leading you to pursue
a goal that isn't actually helping you
in the long run
um now what curiosity does is it
actually protects you from that and it's
because the Curiosity overrides that
emotional kind of pull of your initial
belief so you you know you might have an
initial belief in you know something
like the Paranormal or climate change
denialism or you know any of these
beliefs
um
that maybe don't tally with the
scientific evidence but if you're super
um curious and open-minded it's like
then your love of new law new knowledge
will mean that you are willing to read
that evidence that contradicts that
point of view like you you're so hungry
for knowledge and you're so desperate to
actually get to the bottom of this kind
of problem that you'll you know you'll
read that report that kind of disproves
your belief and then you'll you'll
assimilate it into your knowledge
um and that's really important then for
coming up with a more well-rounded less
myopic kind of world view if you're
constantly doing that you're constantly
kind of accepting you know information
from lots of different sources and then
forming a more rational worldview
because of that so you know for me
curiosity is
um in general for most people is like a
skill that we really should cherish and
cultivate
um now if it's kind of leading you
you know Australia leading you to pursue
to feel like a desperation to know so
much it's actually like um becoming
overwhelming
um I haven't really come across any
research that tells you how to deal with
that but I just wonder if maybe there
it's almost possible to kind of
just focus your curiosity a bit like
pick maybe out of all of the things that
are fascinating you maybe you know like
pick some to focus on at the present and
maybe put some to one side
um while thinking that you know you
could certainly like pursue them in the
future but just kind of making sure that
you're more
um yeah more focused more concentrated
in kind of what you're pursuing I don't
know if that you know speaks to you
personally but that's how I would kind
of deal with it it's like you might want
to know kind of everything
um yeah like you want to travel to every
country in the world but you have to
create a list of priorities for like
places to go burst and create that kind
of itinerary of where you're going to go
and like how you're going to get there
I'll tell you something personal I don't
think I've said this aloud to anyone
outside of here there's a sentence that
drives me I want to learn every Theory
that's ever been constructed so I had
that in me for a little while then I saw
that Feynman on his board Richard
Feynman on his Blackboard before he died
it had some equations but then scrawled
in the corner it said
learn to solve every problem that's ever
been solved and I was like that's
interesting but that's more practical
than for I don't like to solve problems
that are useful I like to know theories
so I'm much more in the air he was on
the ground I mean that's a great example
because I think like Feynman was you
know like one of the most famously
curious people that have has been
written about you know you see it in the
insult biography you see another
scientist descriptions of his behavior
and you know Fineman had definitely had
like his flaws like um but actually I
think in terms of his kind of academic
pursuit of knowledge that Curiosity
really did get him
really you know like so far and it was
actually just like a kind of curiosity
over the way plates were spinning in the
cafeteria they eventually came up
allowed him to come up with his theory
about them uh what was it quantum
yeah exactly but um then want him the
Nobel Prize so he you know like it does
show you what curiosity can achieve but
again I think he
he was super curious but I think he was
kind of he kept it in balance and he was
like new kind of when to focus on one
particular project when to kind of allow
his curiosity to kind of go elsewhere
temporarily so you know that was I think
he's a good model to Polo in that kind
of sense as a writer how many ideas for
books do you have
interesting yeah so I mean I'm working
on my third book no but how many ideas
do you have like on the back burner of
okay project one project two well I've
got it up a couple of ideas kind of you
know they're very vague notes at the
moment
um but I just can't say for certain
whether I would ever pursued them
because
yeah like it's always good to have that
kind of stuff on the back burner that's
interesting you but I think also like I
have to be realistic in what I can
achieve in the amount of time that I
have and also you know I don't know by
the time I've you know between now and
when I've finished my next book someone
else might have already written
something great on one of those topics
and then I don't want to just kind of
rehash what someone else is is writing
so yeah I have a few I'd say maybe I've
got yeah like the one I'm working on
that's been commissioned and then
another couple maybe three but I'm kind
of modeling but I'm mulling over but um
you know they may never come off and I
might you know in the meantime I might
just come up with another idea that just
like really grabs my attention that I
have to write so yeah that's how I work
really you know having lots of ideas
kind of
in the background like uh that I'm
mulling over kind of subconsciously and
consciously but they're not really
making a definite decision until you
know something really grabs my attention
and kind of helps it to all fall into
place and it makes me think actually
this is the one this is what I want to
pursue next I'm super curious now how is
it that you come up with the ideas for
your books is it that you're walking
around and one idea strikes you does it
develop over time generally or is it
like the seed is implanted at once are
you trying to work something out in the
book like you have an idea you're not
sure if it's true so you're going to
write about it and find out did you read
some fact and you're like oh that's
interesting let me explore how does it
work well yeah I mean so say with the
intelligence trap
um you know I had this fascination with
intelligence
um you know that then kind of grew as I
became a science journalist and I kind
of was seeing these people you know
where they're kind of academic
credentials didn't seem to match kind of
their behavior you know enough parts of
their life or their expertise in one
field didn't seem to translate to others
so you know like I had those examples
you know it's a writer who specialized
in Psychology I'd kind of been keeping
on top of the research with that
um but you know it's not like
immediately just
as soon as I came across one piece of
research like it it suddenly I thought
that has to be a book it was much more
of a prolonged process where I kept on
coming across new papers keeping note of
them and then eventually it just kind of
coalesced and that I I guess it is
almost like you know the way Cloud spawn
in a way it's like I felt like there was
just around this new uh nucleus it was
like suddenly this idea started to
emerge and take shape and then you know
it got to this stage where I felt like
well I can write a proposal but this
book
test out for myself but there's the kind
of correct narrative Arc and then you
know once that was done I was pretty
certain that that was something you know
I really wanted to devote like a couple
of years to write
um and it was exactly the same with the
expectation effect of my second book
which but I've been looking into things
like the placebo effect you know since I
became a science journalist like more
than 10 years ago
um
and then there was a bit of a kind of
personal inspiration like an event in my
life where I kind of experienced an
expectation effect for myself
um
but then again it was just like
collecting papers and then suddenly like
a few years later it just I noticed that
actually there was you know already like
a structure had kind of formed it just
kind of occurred to me that you know
these were how I it was like this was
how I could arrange the chapters this
was the story that I felt I could tell
and then I looked into the research you
know to check that it stood up and
actually the more I researched the more
it made sense and you know like I was
finding all these fascinating things
that actually just added to this um
argument I I wanted to make you know
pieces of research I hadn't known about
previously and like stuff I just found
like totally fascinating so yeah that
was how that emerged very similar to the
first one it's like a kind of it
coalesces it takes shape and then
suddenly you think yeah this is a story
that deserves to be a book rather than
like a feature article in a magazine
and when it's coalescing are you making
notes in Google Docs or notion or is it
written on a piece of paper I know I'm
getting in the weeds but I'm I'm an in
the weeds person I'm a details person
yeah no I mean it's in a Word document
so you know I just have like Word
documents that are like you know tens of
pages long with like all kinds of ideas
for like mostly just for like
just noting down pieces of research that
interests me and I'll kind of categorize
it um you know and then I might Plumb
that when I want to come up with like a
an article to pitch to a magazine or if
an editor comes to me and they say like
could you write a piece about you know
conspiracy theories or whatever and
that'll have like these notes that I can
go back to that just kind of suggest to
me kind of what you know what I can say
that's new and interesting
um see it's very much like that and the
books kind of just emerge from that kind
of long list of papers it's you know not
very organized um like it's kind of
split into basic categories but it's not
like I'm being really strategic I think
that is a case of me allowing my
curiosity just to kind of to flow and
just like noting these things down just
because I'm scared of like forgetting
and losing them essentially
how do you deal with this issue of for
myself when I'm writing and I'm writing
books without a publisher it's just tree
disease it's better to say it like that
mainly my impetus is because I don't
understand some subject so let me write
about it for instance paradoxes I'm
writing a book on logical paradoxes or
interpretations of quantum mechanics or
theories of every like a compendium of
different theories of everything
actually anyway as soon as I make an
opinion or state of fact quote unquote I
can find flaws with it and there are
people who have some alternate opinion
so then I research them like that's
actually fairly convincing okay let me
research what the opponent says oh
that's interesting and it goes back and
forth to the point where it's bottomless
at least for myself and then I get to
questions of what is and who am I the
point is like I at least for myself when
trying to put my stake down is something
extremely solid I find that it's sand
and I constantly I'm putting it in
something else and investigating is
seeing okay that's water oh shoot okay
this this I think is Rock no it's
Mercury and so on how do you deal with
that how do you know when you're
supposed to stop and just put your foot
down and say okay this is as good as I
can get it yeah I mean that is really
tough
um especially because science is
constantly evolving and you know there's
always the fear that like you know
between having kind of signed off the
proofs and the book being published
there's some big new study will come you
know they might kind of prove the thesis
but provide that kind of clinching
evidence that you wish you could have
included or that will contradict some
parts and like you know I'm always aware
of that I think and you know even within
the science sometimes you get research
that is contradictory and that's just a
healthy part of science
um you know when I'm writing my books I
really try to kind of acknowledge the
those kinds of nuances
um but I'm really trying to look at like
whether there's a bully a body of
evidence that kind of from lots of
different sources you know lots of
different types of studies it could be
you know medicine like longitudinal
studies it could be laboratory studies
it could be like real world kind of um
interventions you know all of that if
you have enough of those that all point
in the same direction and are showing
the same phenomenon like with the
expectation effect you know if you have
all of these um pieces of evidence
showing that kind of our expectations
can shape our Behavior perception and
Physiology
um in profound ways to create
self-fulfilling prophecies then that's
what I feel I'm contributing you know
I'm somewhere Rising synthesizing that
body of literature and I see it as you
know it's a snapshot in time essentially
like I have to accept that that book
will be as correct as I can possibly
make it at the time of publication but I
can never guarantee that there won't be
other you know cool new studies that
might support a contradictor in the
future and I have to kind of make peace
with that fact that it's a
representation of my thinking and as far
as I could represent it the state of the
science at that time that I was writing
the book and I think that's how readers
take it as well can you explain the
different types of studies you've just
outlined longitudinal studies
Interventional studies and what other
types of studies are there and what's
like the difference between compare and
contrast if you don't mind right sure so
I mean I think you know like in
Psychology and Medicine you can have
like a you know laboratory based study
which is normally in the short term and
you might have someone come in you know
for psychology say well you're
you might test their mindset so looking
this is for the expectation effect like
looking at their beliefs on you know a
particular element of their health or
their Fitness or
um you know what they think about food
and then you might either you might then
kind of give them some kind of tests so
you might be measuring you know how the
what the hormonal response is to the
foods that they're eating and then you
kind of look for a correlation between
you know their beliefs and those
physiological outcomes so you know
standard kind of Laboratory test you
might also have a kind of intervention
within the laboratory so in that case
to kind of look at causality you might
rather than just measuring the mindset
she might actually try to change their
mindsets so you might try to uh change
the way they viewed their own kind of
health and ability to deal with exercise
and then you might measure how they
perform on the treadmill you know see if
if you tell them that they actually have
um good genes for doing exercise that's
going to enhance their endurance do they
then perform better in a test of
Endurance on the treadmill and does that
change things like their physiology like
the gas exchange within their lungs you
know that kind of thing if you do find
that those had had their mindsets
changed then also
um show differences in their physiology
well that's a suggestion of a um of a
causal effect essentially
um so quite a good piece of evidence but
the latter is a an Interventional study
yeah exactly and the former was a uh
well I guess a correlational study
um within the laboratory but then you
could also do these in kind of a real
life situation and I think that would be
much more convincing as if you could
kind of
um get people to kind of change their
mindsets over a period of a month for
example and then you measure differences
in that physiology you know do you see
the predicted effects you can also look
at longitudinal studies which are
correlational but uh they have some
advantages because they often track a
lot of data from a lot of people over a
long period of time so you might track
it over 10 years for 10 000 people and
you might have measured their beliefs
about you know that Fitness or stress at
one point and then you might look at
lots of different outcomes like their
behavior their BMI their risk of Death
at a later time point and you look for
correlations there and you try to um
to kind of control for the conflicting
compounding factors
um now again that that doesn't
necessarily prove causality and there
are issues with that but I think if you
have all these different types of
studies and they're all kind of showing
the predicted effects then like together
is like they're all you know they all
support the argument nothing that's what
I'm really looking for there any one
piece of evidence I think you can
there's going to be some flaws in the
way this study was conducted but I think
like if you start to find you know lots
of lots of data all pointing in the same
direction that makes me much more
confident that there's something solid
there that you're you're observing and
noting and that could be valuable in
applying what is the expectation effect
and what was the Catalyst you said there
is a personal Catalyst for the book
yeah so I mean the expectation effect is
decided that our mindsets which are
these kinds of collective beliefs that
we hold can create self-fulfilling
prophecies and that they can do so
through changes to perception changes to
behavior and changes to physiology so
actually all during things like the
hormonal response in your body or
you know your blood pressure the actions
of the gut
um your bodily movements when you're um
when you're exercising you know all of
those kinds of things
um and and you know like in the book I
kind of look at the ways that this can
our mindsets can influence our briefing
from you know the effects of a
particular drug
um in a hospital
to the
um outcomes of exercise like how you
experience the exercise how your body
responds to the exercise whether it you
know it's efficient or inefficient and
kind of
um performing in particular activity
um how we respond to food how we respond
to a new diet how we respond to sleep
loss even how long we live so I really
looked at you know kind of I think all
of the kind of key areas of our life
that we might be trying to improve with
changes in lifestyle and I'm basically
showing that changes in mindsets Are Not
Alone going to be this kind of secret
Panacea that's going to kind of create
Miracles you know I'm not claiming that
it can that you can change your life
just by changing your beliefs but often
the beliefs are an important component
and they can kind of take the breaks off
of our progress so that when you are
making all of those other beneficial
changes to your kind of exercise regime
or your diet or your sleep but actually
like making sure you're doing so with
the right mindsets can actually make it
a lot more effective and it can you know
kind of bring about all of these
positive outcomes
um
can you give an example before you move
on to the personal one yeah exactly so
um no I kind of hinted at this earlier
you know uh researchers at Stanford kind
of um wanted to see how people's beliefs
about their own Fitness would shape how
they responded to endurance exercise
um so they gave people a real uh genetic
test it looked at the crib one gene
which is associated with um kind of uh
cardiovascular fitness you know and
endurance if you have the kind of good
version of the gene like you find it a
bit easier and more comfortable to do
exercise things like your kind of
internal body temperature just stays in
the kind of comfortable range a bit
longer Gene you know like um yeah
exactly it's great great to have if you
have it I'm a glut and that's like my
advice is I just I can go to buffets and
just eat and eat meat so that's I hope I
have that Gene or if I don't I hope
crispr is making some progress because I
would like to engineer that into me
but here's the thing that you should
remember then
um because so they did the real genetic
test but they gave people false feedback
so they told some people you have the
good Gene good version of the jeans some
people were told they're the bad version
of the Gene and then they did their kind
of endurance exercise and what the
researchers found was that yeah like the
gene does have an effect but so did
people's expectations of uh whether they
had the gene so this this feedback was
sham feedback so some who had the good
version were told they have the bad
version vice versa and actually those
expectations independently affected how
people did the exercise
um and you know in some cases According
to some of the physiological measures
the expectations were actually more
important than the effects of the gene
itself so when they were looking at like
the efficiency of the lungs well that
depended more on the expectations that
you had the good Gene than whether you
actually had the good Gene that's
interesting speak to your um experience
of being like a rapacious full yeah they
did exactly the same experiment looking
at people's
um a gene that was associated with um
satiety so wherever people feel they
need to eat more to be full
um and again my fan but actually those
expectations did shape how much people
ate
um but also shaped like the response of
the uh the gut the hormonal response
there was one particular hormone that's
linked to satiety that was very closely
linked to the expectations of whether
they would be full or not thanks to this
Gene so you know again it's like it's
like I said just in be answered to your
previous question like I'm not claiming
that like our genes don't matter because
they did have an effect too but what you
can what you can see here is that
actually even if you have the bad Gene
you don't have to see it as being
deterministic in some way like you can
accept that actually your expectations
are also playing a role and then you can
look for ways to kind of change those
expectations and then that can be
beneficial to you
and now the personal bit
yeah so I mean this was you know I think
we all know what the placebo effect is
it's where you kind of take a sham drug
like a sugar pill and then you
you're told that it's the real thing and
then you know you experience kind of
pain relief or
um you know changing blood pressure due
purely to your beliefs and that's quite
well established
um but there's the suburb phenomenon
called the nosiba effect
um which is like the placebo effects
evil twin
um if you expect to become ill then
those beliefs can actually create
symptoms of sickness so they can do
things like Amplified
um the transmission of pain signals so
something that would be like a small
irritation suddenly becomes agonizing
um they can actually change things like
the vasculature of the brain so they can
create a migraine and it's actually you
know taking form in your brain it's
actually changing the way your brain is
responding
um and I experienced that and you know
Dino super effect has been really widely
studied in people's cider boats to
particular drugs so if you're told you
might experience a headache after taking
a pill people are much more likely to
experience that headache even if they're
taking a placebo pill and they're told
that Michael's a headache they get the
headache um
and I I've been going for a period of
depression in my life
um and I was taking these like very
standard antidepressant pills and my
doctor you know she was obliged to do
she told me that I might experience you
know headaches as a result of taking the
pills and I did and they were super
painful like I really found it difficult
to focus at work
um you know I thought it was like and it
did feel like such a sharp pain like you
know an ice pick was kind of going broke
the skull or something
um so pretty nasty but at the time I was
also kind of you know just by chance
looking into
the placebo effect and I came across
this research on the nosiba effect and
actually that knowledge of the nasiba
back tonight I checked the data for the
drug itself and I saw that actually a
lot of the side effects that people were
reporting were influenced by a nocebo
effect
um that knowledge actually then helped
to relieve the pain it just kind of
I just questioned like well is it
inevitable that I'm experiencing this
pain it certainly felt like it was you
know direct kind of
um physiological response to the drug
but you know it just made me think well
maybe it's just my expectations and
actually yeah just opening my mind up to
that possibility kind of it led me not
to catastrophize the pain and not to
feel so anxious about the pain and that
in turn then stopped me feeling the pain
itself and so you know after a day or so
I actually just didn't have any of the
headaches at all and I continued my
treatment and it you know it worked
remarkably well and if I hadn't learned
that I would have probably given up that
treatment it would have been a waste of
like you know perfectly good
um line of treatment that actually
proved successful so that experience
really told me that like expectation
effects are real that you know it's not
made up it's not imagined because that
pain to me was just as real as when I'd
ever had a migraine in the past and we
know that it's related to physiological
changes in the brain and so I just
started thinking well like how else
could our expectations shape our
experience like what else is it doing to
us and how could we use this knowledge
to our advantage and so that's when I
collected all of those papers you know
years later I realized that I had enough
and it took the shape of a book that I
really wanted to write so so many
questions I have man let me prioritize
right how do you know if what you
experienced was the nocebo effect or you
just had the actual effect and what you
learned afterwards was a positive
placebo effect that neutralized
perfect
I mean that is a possibility I suppose
um
I mean in this case I think it's
unlikely because I'd actually when I was
looking into these um
you know my particular brand of
antidepressant pills
um you know like the vast majority of
people experiencing headaches
um we're experiencing it because of the
expectation the difference between those
in the placebo arm of the clinical
trials of this drug and the people
actually taking the drug was you know
tiny I'm not even sure if it was
Clinic please you know like I'm not
clinically significant statistically
significant so it really was very likely
that I was experiencing a nocebo effect
this podcast is a part of a series
that's extremely practical so we're
gonna talk about steps that people can
take to utilize the expectation effect
in their life and then also later on
we're going to talk about learning
because in particular learning extremely
confounding graduate level math and
physics because many people on this
channel want to know how can I utilize
some of the lessons from the
intelligence trap and or the
expectations effect to accelerate by
learning in this case new knowledge
nullified the nosi buffet now how does
one have new knowledge that gives a
placebo effect because I can imagine if
someone was to tell you by the way the
positive effects you're feeling that's
just in your head that may reduce it
rather than amplify it how do you
consciously employ some strategy to
utilize the placebo effect yeah and I
mean this has been the big toilet that
had like really put a barrier on kind of
placebo research for decades
um but actually there's lots of exciting
new research that kind of helps us to
get over them and basically all of this
research shows that you don't need
um deception to take advantage of
expectation of Apes now one of the kind
of studies I like most looks at um
they're called open label placebos
they're like non-deceptive placebos so
there was a study from Portugal where
the researchers
um took people with chronic back pain
and you know they've been struggling the
patients have been struggling with with
this for a while
um and they actually gave them a a jar
of placebo pills that clearly said
Placebo pills take two a day like the
pills were kind of bright orange you
know quite striking but they knew that
they were didn't contain an active
ingredient
but the researchers also gave the
participants the kind of uh presentation
about the the placebo effect but all of
this evidence showing that actually good
expectations can help to relieve pain
that sometimes the brain itself can
create its own endogenous opioids it
kind of has its inner Pharmacy that it
can tap that will help to produce its
own painkillers
um they learn all of these things and
then they were told like you don't have
to kind of take our word for it like you
don't have to you know convince yourself
that this is true like artificially kind
of lie to yourself or repeat to Mantra
like just kind of you know listen to the
evidence and you know process it as you
want but you do have to then take the
pills like the ritual of taking the
pills that's really important so take
one in the morning one in the evening
like do that for the next
um week and what the researchers found
was that actually
you know the ritual of the pills and
bind with that information that they'd
been given that kind of empowering
information about the mind-body
connection the bat alone was enough to
produce a clinically significant
decrease in
um pain symptoms that they were feeling
so reduced it by I think it's 29 which
is the kind of threshold but you know if
you're trying to approve a new drug for
pain relief
um and you know then they the kind of
participants went away the trial was
ended it was written up for five years
later the researchers kind of boosted
these same participants and found that
even five years later they were still
like managing and coping better than the
participants who hadn't received the
placebo pills those had just continued
their
um treatment as usual so that really
suggested that actually
knowing about the expectation effect
knowing about these benefits can in
itself Empower you and kind of can
create the expectation of pain relief in
this case but actually then produces the
benefits that you want without any
detention that's now been replicated a
few different times for different
illnesses
um and we know that there are other kind
of tactics too so actually you can do
away with the kind of sham treatment
altogether in some cases and just give
people a kind of psychological therapy
that just helps to them to form
optimistic but realistic expectations of
the recovery from surgery for example so
you you kind of give them information
that allays their worries about the
effects of the surgery and helps them to
plan out this kind of recovery that they
would like to see against them to feel
excited about all of the kind of new
activities they'll be able to do when
they when they feel better and that that
psychological therapy alone can produce
some of the benefits that you would want
to see they leave Hospital more quickly
they return to work more quickly may
also show differences in signs of kind
of inflammation within the body um the
lower the inflammation the kind of
quicker the biological recovery and so
that's just two ways that you can kind
of apply the principle of the placebo
effect but without being deceptive and
then you know in other areas of life I
kind of explain how you can apply the
same kinds of principles to things like
um you know managing sleep loss or kind
of boosting your experience of exercise
you don't have to fool yourself into
thinking that you
um
have those good genes for exercise for
example to actually benefit from that
kind of uh expectation effect it's
actually just enough for you to start
reappraising the things that you'd
associated with exercise and kind of
changing your assumptions kind of just
being very objective about it really
um so yeah it's Lots that's what's so
exciting to me is that actually you know
we don't have to be this kind of
self-delusional Pollyanna is kind of
always kind of fooling themselves into
thinking things are better than they are
it's all just about kind of having this
knowledge of what the brain can do and
then trying to think of like clever ways
of applying that and of kind of forming
or reappraising your old assumptions and
kind of forming new expectations that
that can be beneficial and Optimum to
you what can one do specifically to up
raise their level of sleep so that's
something I need even sleep quality let
alone the hours and also like I
mentioned this is going to be a part of
a series on learning extremely difficult
mathematics and physics so what can some
someone who's watching this due to
increase the rate of learning utilizing
the expectation effect yeah sure so
um
to take
um sleep burst uh you know like
a lot of
a lot of sleep loss comes from a kind of
fear of not getting enough sleep
um so you know like we know like it's
well accepted amongst um kind of
cognitive behavioral therapists who help
people with insomnia that we can develop
all of these kind of really damaging
beliefs about the sleep that we're
getting so if you've had sleep loss in
the past then that kind of creates an
anxiety about not being able to get to
sleep in the future and those anxieties
put you in a state of high arousal so
that you
um find it much harder to get to sleep
because your your brain is awful alert
um now one way around that unintuitively
is that actually if you try to stay
awake
is a kind of ironic interesting therapy
tried to stay awake your you know
studies suggest that you're more likely
to fall asleep so I don't think that's a
case of like just
you know staying up partying and like
expecting it to come kind of
miraculously but you know when you're
lying in bed and if you feel like you're
desperate to fall asleep actually don't
like try to think of something that's
going to stay keep you awake and you'll
probably find then you're kind of
drowsing and falling off naturally
um so that's one strategy mindfulness is
a good way if you can learn mindfulness
and you can apply it well that can be
another good way of just kind of
avoiding those kind of fretful thoughts
as you fall asleep and it's almost like
having that non-judgmental
um awareness of what you're thinking so
you stop catastrophizing like if you've
got all that stuff going around in your
head like you kind of notice it and let
it go without judging yourself for it um
that can be beneficial
um but equally important I think is
looking at our expectations of what the
Sleep loss is going to do to the day
ahead so if you're struggling to get
sleep or maybe you've been asleep and
you wake up like always happens to me
you wake up at like two o'clock in the
morning
um you can immediately start thinking
well like if I don't get to sleep now
then tomorrow I'm gonna be wrecked I'm
going to be irritable I'm not going to
be able to meet my deadline you know all
of those things
um actually just stop thinking about
those events and the reason that you can
do that is that the research shows that
actually is those expectations that
create the symptoms of Sleepless the
next day so there have been lots of
research longitudinal studies like I
mentioned also laboratory intervention
studies that gave people false feedback
about their Sleep Quality they all
suggest that if you expect to suffer
because of your sleep loss you're more
likely to suffer the next day from your
sleep loss so you tell someone that
they've had really you get them in the
lab and attach electrodes to them let
them kind of sleep sleep and then tell
them the next day that they have
actually that they had a terrible
night's sleep according to the
electrical recordings that expectation
will then cause them the next day to
feel more fatigued to struggle to
concentrate to to be more irritable
that's extremely interesting because
there's obviously the news which outputs
dangerous messages when I say dangerous
I mean messages of danger and part of it
is they want to inform people like part
of a deleterious they they're trying to
get views but let's say optimistically
they're trying to inform but by doing so
they may create conditions that make the
danger worse and then Michael Walker of
the Sleep books Matt Walker of what
what's this book called
um
why we sleep yeah okay so Matt Walker he
talks about the detrimental effects of
sleep loss and partly that I think since
I started caring about my sleep I start
to have sleep issues I had an aura ring
I don't I no longer use the aura ring
because I found myself being fanatic
about checking my stats and then
worrying when they weren't optimal so
that's interesting because you want to
inform but at the same time informing
may do more harm than good how does one
navigate around that
I mean it's interesting you say about uh
Matt Walker's book you know I'm a big
fan actually but um you know I have read
like blogs by kind of sleep scientists
who've you know said that they're
actually worried that like it's created
a lot of anxiety about sleep that then
is leading more people to come to sleep
clinics with sleep problems and that the
anxiety is kind of exacerbating their
issues now I think you know it's a kind
of like we were talking about earlier
it's like
you know should we give information to
people like we want to be informed but
should we be giving information that's
actually going to harm people's um
quality of life and I think we should I
think we need to know you know the truth
about kind of the importance of sleep
because you know you might be suffering
from the kinds of sleep problems that
we've spoken about that are fueled by
anxiety but you know there's also lots
of people who just aren't giving
themselves enough time to get to sleep
and then you know you want those people
to be able to make a better informed
decision of kind of their lifestyle
um but I think the message can be
presented in such a way that it doesn't
kind of catastrophize the effects of a
loss of sleep and I think maybe what's
been lost in some of this messaging is
that you know the occasional sleep loss
that you might get doesn't have to be a
catastrophe for you so you know if you
wake up
um and then we looked at night for half
an hour that doesn't mean that you're
gonna struggle the next day but look but
we can develop this belief that it will
do so any slight disturbance becomes
like a serious worry for us
um so I think we need to acknowledge
that we need to kind of put things in
proportion
um
then we can also look at things like um
that have been proven to work so you
know I think like hopefully just by
understanding a bit about this
expectation of age you know people
who've read that chapter I've heard that
it has kind of immediately helped them
work their sleep and I was like super
pleased about that but if people are
having these kind of continuing problems
with their sleep you know they're really
struggling to get
um to get enough each night and it's
becoming something that's really
damaging their lifestyle well then they
can go to a specialized sleep therapist
who won't put them on sleeping pills
which you know the efficacy of sleeping
pills is you know questionable but
instead they will help them to change
those beliefs in a more kind of
organized program so through cognitive
behavioral therapy or mindfulness based
therapy they'll help them to deal with
those kind of beliefs that are keeping
them awake at night and then causing
them this distress the next day and
those and that therapy working through
practical problems talking about the
science and the evidence and you know
giving them that knowledge that can be
really beneficial for curing insomnia
too so I would say if you have this kind
of um prolonged problem you know do get
help but it doesn't have to be a
pharmaceutical solution like there are
but psychological means of dealing with
sleep loss that can take advantage of
the expectation effect
much of this has so far been about
ameliorating what is a medical issue
what about if we have no issue and we
want to accelerate in a certain area for
instance learning Arcane math physics
computer science philosophy how does one
utilize some of these techniques does
one take a pill in the morning can they
self-assign the pill does one inject is
injecting better yeah
um you know I mean I wish I really
kicked myself that I didn't know about
all of the science before I did my own
degree in mathematics because you know
it's a tough degree
um
I you know I I did fine but like I think
I could have done better if I'd known
all but I know now about the psychology
of learning
um and I think one of the lessons that
really
really chimes with me and also you know
it's relevant whatever job you do but
especially with learning
needs to reappraise the effects of
prostration
um
and I think this gets to the kind of
Heart of like how we can use the
expectation effect more generally
um so for example if you're
exercising you're working out you feel
aches and your muscles you feel out of
breath you can assume that those uh
symptoms are kind of a sign of your lack
of fitness and you can kind of
catastrophize them and that you think
like you start telling yourself you have
this negative internal monologue that's
like I'm a failure I'm struggling I'm
really unfair I'm not gonna manage to
like to get through this workout and
you know the research on the expectation
of it shows that actually just changing
the way the meaning you assign to those
feelings can change your performance so
if you see rather than like those being
those symptoms as being like um
you know detrimental negative signs of
failure if you actually just say as
you're pushing your body to its limits
of building string that's actually
really beneficial and it helps you to
enjoy the exercise more it creates the
endorphin rush you know it can really
build up your stamina uh just by
changing that mindset and I think
exactly the same thing happens in
learning and there are studies that show
this so if you're learning arcade maths
but it's really inevitable unless you
are some kind of like incredible genius
that you're gonna feel frustrated
sometimes you're going to not be able to
solve that problem but the concepts
aren't going to stick that you there's
going to be some kind of Gap in your
knowledge that you're really struggling
to overcome that kind of Gap in
understanding
what the the research shows is that you
can appraise that frustration
as in the same way that someone who's
struggling at the gym appraises the
muscle aches you can see it as a sign of
failure as a kind of sign that you're
not smart enough that you're not
intelligent enough that you that you're
not learning that you're not progressing
uh you can just say it purely
detrimentally
or you connect that and this is also
totally rational and actually true you
can accept the fact that um frustration
is just an inevitable and important part
of learning in the same way that you're
pushing the body when you're working out
you're pushing your brain to build new
connections to Grapple with really
complex difficult ideas and if you
weren't feeling frustrated you wouldn't
be stretching yourself you wouldn't be
building your knowledge and what the
research shows is that when you come to
accept and even embrace the frustration
and you recognize that it's crucial for
learning but that actually helps you to
learn better it helps your determination
and perseverance but to actually almost
like frees up part of your mind because
you're no longer feeling all that kind
of anxiety it's not going through your
hair taking up your mental resources
you're just accepting it and then
getting on with the problem and that
that you know Lesson by lesson like can
a class by class you know Problem by
problem that's going to help you with
your progress and that's definitely
something that I noticed in my own
degree I just didn't know the science
behind it it was almost once I relaxed
into problems and just could kind of sit
with them without panicking when I
didn't get it immediately but that
actually just was incredibly important
for me to be able to progress a lot more
quickly and that's exactly the same when
I'm writing journalism now or writing my
books you know sometimes structuring
like a chapter is really frustrating
because you just don't see how you can
fit the pieces together in the right way
and you have to have that kind of
structure like you're playing almost
like a jigsaw in your mind like trying
to see the most elegant most
comprehensible most enticing way for a
subject and the more I just relax into
that frustration and accept that it's
just you know a creative block is kind
of part of being creative if you weren't
experiencing that it would just be a
kind of administrative task whereas
actually the frustration is the
creativity recognizing that actually
helps with my job today too so I think
it's something that can be applied in
all kinds of areas but absolutely with
maps I think the thing that holds so
many people back is that they get in
this kind of panic
um and actually just relaxing into that
and accepting it and even embracing it
is so powerful
what else would you do differently as an
undergrad
um I think going back to crew to
curiosity though it mentioned uh yeah
and the benefits of curiosity for
reading I think with sometimes a
subject-like Maps or physics you know
it's very abstract and it can be quite
difficult for you to kind of
attach it to something really meaningful
in your life
um you might automatically have this
kind of Fascination where I don't know
like number Theory or whatever but um
but for me I was always more interested
in the applied maps and the pure maths
um felt like a kind of needless
distraction so I I was really dedicated
in trying to learn it but it never felt
pure maths felt like a distraction yeah
exactly compared to the applied Maps
which is like what I was really
interested in and I had no option like I
had to learn it
um you know and I think I put in a lot
of effort and I did fine like you know
it's not like I failed that class or
anything but um but knowing what I know
about curiosity now I think actually I
should have tried really rather than
just putting kind of
working like a Workhorse just kind of
putting in me out as I should have
thought a bit more creatively about how
to cultivate curiosity and what I was
learning and something really simple I
think like learning about the lives of
the mathematicians Behind these kind of
theories that I was learning that you
know I was never going to be tested on
any of that biographical information but
I know from the science of curiosity
that that could have been enough to kind
of spark an interest that would have
then had this spillover effect and made
the whole process of learning much more
meaningful for me because I know really
like people-centered person you know
like I love hearing not just about big
ideas about the kind of story behind the
ideas which is what I bring to my
journalism but I think I could have
brought that to my degree and actually
that kind of that you know enticing
myself into a subject could have been so
beneficial have you read the biography
of Da Vinci by Walter Isaacson I have
yeah both no one that you I think
there's no one in history that could be
described as being as curious as he was
but yeah yeah and in the book Walter
says in the beginning that he has
described Steve Jobs as a genius and
Einstein is a genius and so-and-so as a
genius but he said he was careful to not
call Da Vinci a genius because he feels
like virtually everything Da Vinci had
done could be cultivated in other people
it was just about being immensely
curious like he would paint on the wall
a line and then get him and his friend
to guess what is the length of that line
in one of the notes he scrawled what is
the function of the tongue of a
hummingbird or or a woodpecker something
like that and it turns out then he's
like whoa what the heck why would anyone
think of that firstly and then does a
bird beat its wings down faster than it
brings it up that's a question you just
you don't even think to ask and he would
ask them and turns out they had
extremely interesting answers there was
something different about the
woodpecker's tongue yeah exactly but I
mean I guess I would disagree with um
uh with him uh and I think like
that is a but it was that Curiosity that
was behind
um Da Vinci's genius you know so and it
was exceptional and I agreed that other
people could cultivate that Curiosity
potentially but then I think also people
could cultivate the traits that made
Steve Jobs I guess that's what I feel
about genius is that we especially
having written the expectation of it is
that
we see it as being something that's kind
of god-given but actually you can break
it down and that's I mean there's so
many traits that contribute to genius
it's not like there's one secret but I
think they are all uh kind of can be
cultivated and and then you know
sometimes just for someone to be
recognized as a genius there's also kind
of good luck like you know you have to
be in the right place at the right time
to make your amazing Discovery like fine
man if you haven't been watching those
spinning plates and hadn't come up with
that particular idea at that particular
time maybe he wouldn't have won his
Nobel Prize you know so I think genius
is a very messy topic and I but I think
you know DaVinci yeah we can learn a lot
from him but we can learn a lot from all
of these other people today I agree with
all of what you said minus the luck part
but it's not that I disagree about the
luck it's more about that if we follow
the logic of the luck it's not so you
could say well 50 of their success was
luck well if you follow the logic they
got you to that to that 50 you could
drag that all the way to 99.99 999
because you could just end up with the
logic of Dr Manhattan I think his name
was from the Watchman who said yeah but
for even you to be here every atom
needed to coalesce with this Adam and
this organism needed to not die and so
on and so the chances of you being here
are so astronomically zero so you could
follow that line to say essentially
every single aspect of you is luck and
there's almost zero free will if free
will even exist at all and then that has
its own downsides that's why I have
issues with any arguments about luck
like there's obviously positive about
luck because you don't want to say every
single thing in a person is due to their
own merits or that they're flawed in
some way like that's horrible but then
logically speaking any argument for an
incorporation of even 10 luck can be
pushed to 99.9999 luck how do you deal
with that
and I guess I kind of do you know see a
point and I kind of agree with it and
you know I like to think that say
someone like Brian went you know if he
hadn't been in that container at that
time he would have come up with the
discovery some other way and because I
think it was his combination of you know
intelligence and curiosity and
open-mindedness and dedication I'm gonna
grit all of these things the men that he
created his own luck in that he took
that opportunity and ran a bit but if he
hadn't had that opportunity there might
have been another one that he would have
had instead who would have also led to
some amazing Discovery so you know I do
think you know it still is within uh
within our control and you can you can
maximize your chances you might not be
if there's no foolproof way to become a
genius or to be recognized as a genius
but you can absolutely maximize your
chances of that by cultivating those
kinds of traits so one way that it can
be conceptualized is like yes there is a
lottery but every time you persevere
it's like you're playing that Lottery
again and again and again so yeah is
that one way or is that incorrect like
yeah no that's it you have yet you have
to be in it to win it essentially and
you can you can be smart about the kind
of way that you play
you know book cards that you've been
given in life essentially and I think
like we mustn't neglect like all of the
structural factors that mean it's much
harder for people of like certain
backgrounds to succeed where others
might find it much easier so I'm not
definitely not discounting the fact that
like there are structural barriers that
we need to remove to give people uh
equal opportunities or more equal
opportunities but you know given most
circumstances being the way they are
there are still things that we can do
that will maximize our chances that will
kind of give us a bit more luck in that
Lottery of Life David what is
evidence-based wisdom
um so this is kind of trying to apply
the same intellectual rigor that we had
with the study of intelligence to the
study of wisdom
um obviously wisdom has been You Know
spoken about a lot and philosophy but in
science people had really you know
ignored ignored the question I avoided
the question of what makes on what whys
can we measure it and then this
researcher called Igor Grossman
um really attempted to tackle this huge
problem and he looked at all of the
philosophical definitions of wisdom and
he distilled them to uh six different uh
metacognitive uh kind of tendencies that
we might have and you know to name a few
of them as things like intellectual
wisdom intellectual humility essentially
you know people since Socrates had
argued that to be wise you have to have
a very uh definite knowledge of the
limits of your of your capabilities and
to accept when you don't know something
um it's the ability to reach a
compromise the ability to look for other
people's perspectives so you're not just
kind of myopically focused on your
particular viewpoint but you're you're
looking for other people's too so he
you know gathered these together and
then he started designing tests that
would measure them some of these tests
were quite involved but it would involve
um people looking at a kind of article
that might be from a dear Abbey column I
think like an agonyon color outlining a
problem or it could be an article about
the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and he would
ask people to talk out loud about what
they thought of these issues how the
situations might be resolved potentially
you know really to kind of talk through
uh their thinking on these complex
situations and then psychologists would
rate how they performed on all of those
different elements of wisdom like
intellectual humility did these people
actually acknowledge that they didn't
have all the information they needed to
hand and did they outline what they
would like to know before coming to a
conclusion that kind of thing
uh what he found was that those
uh those measures actually correlate
really well with important outcomes in
life and when it comes to things like uh
people's emotional well-being uh the
health you know all of these really
important things there's a state of
their relationships the measures of
wisdom actually came out as being more
important than uh independent measures
of IQ that had also taken so it really
proved that wisdom is something that can
be measured scientifically and then Igor
looked at ways to cultivate wisdom to
make people wiser and one example of
that which I loved is this uh uh
phenomenon called self-distancing and
that is essentially just getting
yourself to look at a particular
situation from an outside perspective
if you're American and you are reasoning
about the forthcoming elections for
example rather than just talking about
the situation from your own perspective
you might
consider how someone from Iceland or
Australia might view the situation
um if you're talking about a personal
problem you might imagine instead that
you were advising a friend with a
similar problem what he found was that
this actually
improves people's scores and wise
reasoning it actually helps them to
reason in a more sophisticated way about
the issues at hand and the reason is
that it stops us from feeling so
attached emotionally to the particular
problem and to our pre-existing
Viewpoint so it helps us to question our
assumptions to look at those different
perspectives that we might not consider
if we feel totally immersed in the
situation at hand if we a reasoning from
the position of an American talking
about the US election sort of reasoning
as ourselves about the dissolution of
our marriage he found that it could be
very powerful in helping people to be
more objective more rational wiser about
the situations that they were describing
and it's something that we can all do in
our lives is to just apply this very
simple technique
did he come up with a number akin to IQ
but for wisdom like your WQ no so you
know he didn't come up with a kind of
wisdom quotient
um but you know it was in a way like the
IQ the intelligence question is a great
way you know you look there's a
comparison always a comparison with the
average
um so maybe that's something he would
consider in the future but I think more
importantly he's really looking up
anyone could measure their Baseline uh
kind of wise reasoning score according
to his different tests and then they
could try to see an improvement in that
score so you could at least look at your
own personal trajectory even if you're
not trying to compare across the
population the beauty of the IQ test is
that it's difficult to fake you can
practice IQ tests and you can score
higher but with a survey I imagine with
a survey like the wisdom tester says Hey
do you take other people's viewpoints
into account you could imagine I think
it's more socially acceptable and wise
so I'm gonna say yes I I do 5 out of
five you could imagine that you can
falsify that information so is there a
way of constructing a wisdom test that
takes into account that people may not
say what is accurate about themselves
yeah I mean so I think some of eagles
Tesla questionnaires in the way that you
describe so self-reported I mean no
surprisingly people are quite honest and
self-reported question and so we know
that from personality questionnaires for
example but people people's responses
often do correspond to what their
friends would say about them so they're
not always lying although there might be
a slight bias tools are more positive
you know attribute
um but actually in a lot of these tests
you know they're having to prove that
they were capable of doing that so if
they were reasoning about the U.S
elections they would actually have to
take someone else's perspective but they
would actually have to they would have
to show that kind of integration of what
a Democrat would think compared to a
Republican and to balance them and to
kind of draw connections between the two
and to look for the ways that there
might be a compromise on a particular
political opinion or particular
political problem and so they're
actually having shown that having to
show that they did that it wasn't just
them saying Oh yeah I'm brilliant at
this
um so yeah I think he's he's considered
that and it does it does seem that
people's self-reported responses
correspond with their actual abilities
to do that and also that even when you
do things like this self-distancing
exercise that that's having a real
impact on what they're doing how they're
going about their reasoning what are the
rationality coefficients
so that was that is research where
someone has tried to look at a more
direct comparison to be uh in
intelligence uh quotient
um that's where by Keith stanovic who's
another Canadian researcher you know
brilliant mind who's really taken the
work of people like Daniel carderman all
of these uh cognitive biases that we
know that exist like the some cost
fallacy that we mentioned earlier things
like um temporal discounting which is
whether you
are able to overlook a more immediate
reward something a bigger reward later
on that kind of thing you know how how
you fall on that kind of spectrum of
potential responses for uh you know when
you're willing to kind of have a cut up
all of that kind of
um literature on decision making he's
really looked at very carefully and uh
he's shown that there are reliable
individual differences between people
that can be measured with tests uh which
is something that Daniel conman hadn't
looked at the differences between people
he'd just shown a general average
tendency whereas Keith stanovic was
really looking at are some people
consistently more susceptible to bias
than other people and he found that that
is true some people do tend to suffer
from all kinds of biases both of us are
more resilient against biases and then
he compared that to their IQ scores
their SAT scores and the U.S education
system in all of these cases he found
that there was a correlation with
measures of intelligence but the
intelligence alone didn't describe
people's rationality so what I mean by
that is you could still have someone who
is highly intelligent but who scored
very low on the rationality quotient and
vice versa did he say what the
correlation was
it really depended on what kind of test
they were using and also it did depend
on what kind of bias they were looking
at the Suncoast fallacy
um
I believe or temporal discounting I
believe the correlation was almost zero
you know like surprisingly like people
really weren't more rational in those
kinds of situations that they were
measuring
um if they were more intelligent it just
didn't seem to make a difference so what
other elements of his rationality
equation that did depend more on
intelligence and that tended to be the
things that I think would be covered in
academic education so how he also looked
at things like how you would read
statistics like whether people are able
to understand like absolute risk
relative risk
um all of that kind of statistical
reasoning and as you might expect if
you're you have a higher SAT score you
probably were paying more attention in
your maths classes and so you are better
able when asked to actually
calculate those different risks those
are really important elements of
rationality and actually they can be
taught which is positive so but yeah
it's not like intelligence was
completely unrelated to all elements of
rationality but certainly for some some
areas where you would expect that a
smarter person would just automatically
make the more rational decision he
didn't find that at all so he does he
says it supports this idea but you know
smart people can make terribly
irrational decisions and he calls that
phenomenon discretionalia which he
compares to dyslexia
um so dyslexia is the you might have a
high IQ person who has a particular
problem with literacy and with reading
in particular and similarly with
disrasionalia you might have someone
with a high IQ who's just really
irrational they just really struggle to
come up with
to read data rationally and logically
and to weigh off evidence and to come up
with a conclusion based on that data so
he yeah he considers this to be a kind
of societal problem that there needs to
be targeted with like interventions that
help to cultivate rationality
so stanovich's terminology he calls it
the quotient so it's not coefficients no
it's the rationale well that's the
informal name is the rationality
quotient but yeah his book was called
the rationality quotient so he's
definitely promoting this idea like the
intelligence question yeah and there
wasn't just one there were several types
of rationality quotients or there was
just one like right RQ and that's it not
RQ underscore one yeah no exactly so
basically a bit like with IQ test
actually you break it into kind of um
stop tests so you you know an IQ you
might have like the verbal subtest the
nonverbal reasoning subtest you know um
lots of different types of uh of
different problems that it's measuring
and there's a correlation between all of
them but actually the correlation
between one and another might vary so
you know there's a kind of central
Factor we say uh which is
someone's kind of general intelligence
but
and if you're better at one you're more
likely to be better at another cognitive
task but it doesn't mean that you're
automatically brilliant to all of them
if you a brilliant one it's the same
with rationality that you see a
correlation between the different
subtests but actually there's still
enough variation within a person so you
might have a particular strength in one
area of rationality but a weakness in
another was his conclusion that high IQ
individuals generally have a slightly
higher RQ but in particular for certain
subtypes of RQ they're lower
yeah that's exactly it and but um but
even
you know and they're even amongst
individuals you know even amongst high
IQ individuals you'll have like enough
variation the RQ rationality is
something that we should be measuring
and then cultivating separately from IQ
and the other kind of academic uh
disciplines that we look at so he gives
the example of if you're recruiting you
know some recruiters do use IQ tests
still to kind of work out who's the best
person to employ but they're not really
measuring accurately rationality and you
want a rational Workforce really you
don't want someone who's gonna fall for
fake news uh fall for [__] from some
kind of other company and make a bad
investment you want a rational Workforce
So He suggests that actually we should
be using the rationalis equation as a
means of selecting candidates and also
just as a means of identifying who could
do some training like who needs to learn
more about maybe
how to read statistics or these to have
that awareness raised about things like
the sunk cost fallacy so they don't fall
for it in the future
is there a relationship between
high IQ and arrogance uh I wouldn't I
don't know if anyone's looked at it like
that but Keith stanovic had looked at
the biased blind spot
um and that's essentially
you are someone like you tell them about
these cognitive biases and then you ask
them
do you think you're gonna suffer from
those Pisces yourself and what he found
was that people the higher IQs tended to
think that they were less susceptible
than the other people
um they over exaggerated their
um
their resilience their protection
against the biases so they thought they
were much better than they actually were
and that was more likely the more
intelligent they were essentially so in
that you know in that sense I think the
biased blind spot is an example of
intellectual arrogance and it's a
serious problem because if you don't
have awareness of the ways that your
reasoning might uh fail then you're less
likely to try to account for that how
can an individual listening slash
watching this increase their RQ the
rationality quotient right so this is
still
um an area of research but I think like
those very strong evidence that we can
improve elements of rationality
um so you know just learning about these
biases there are some studies that
showed that once you have that awareness
and as long as you make sure that you
apply that awareness as well that you
look when you're making a new decision
but you start to consider the biases
that might be influencing your decision
and then try to account for them you
know that's a learnable skill so that's
one thing we can look at these books you
know like the intelligent strap like
thinking fast and slow you know we can
learn from those books and then try to
apply it and that will improve our
rationality
um more generally I think like there's
research looking at critical thinking so
identifying logical fallacies learning
to
um to avoid just relying on like our gut
reaction so whether we think
um
whether intuitively something feels
right to actually override that and to
question our assumption and then to look
for the evidence that contradicts it
that's something that we can all learn
to do that's going to reduce your
susceptibility to something like
motivated reasoning or the my side bias
um another useful strategy when you're
trying to appraise different pieces of
information is to just try to put
yourself in an alternative Viewpoint
where you you question whether you would
be as convinced by a piece of evidence
if it's conclusions weren't the opposite
so it's kind of intricate that but if
you wanted to
if you were a republican say and you saw
a report that supported
a Democrats
uh Economic Policy
um now you might instantly dismiss it
because it doesn't come to the
conclusion that you would want it to
take but what you can do to make sure
that you're not just dismissing that
evidence
unfairly is to stop and think well would
I have spotted the same Applause in this
piece in this report if it had actually
supported a republican Viewpoint instead
um that's just one example but it's very
much just trying to to check that you're
even-handed in the way that you're
applying your critical thinking skills
in the much earlier example of Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle and the Paranormal
how does one know that what he was doing
was in fact false so one way is we say
well the scientific consensus is so
what's up but then my issue with that is
that there's a beautiful study in your
book which I love I'm gonna start to
quote about if you give a test on gun
violence to people who are conservative
and liberal and subtle reasoning shows
that the gun violence in this example
the laws that are for gun control end up
causing more gun violence but you have
to be extremely careful with your math
in order to come to that conclusion that
the conservatives were more likely to
find that loophole or the not trivial
reasoning in order to get to that
conclusion and the Liberals were more
likely to say oh yeah gun control
clearly reduces gun crime and then vice
versa so then that made me think okay
well if we ever appeal to Scientific
consensus we have to wait for political
leaning and the majority of scientists
are liberal like 90 percent are liberal
their studies on this so then do we wait
consensus by that how do we do that so
that's my issue because there are so
many aspects of this world of the themes
that I try to investigate in theories of
everything that I used to just dismiss
and disparage like near-death
experiences or connecting Consciousness
with quantum mechanics or even UFOs also
I was looking into the placebo effect
whereas prior I thought that it was just
a measly effect like a bit of pain
relief I didn't think it had much Merit
to it I'm not saying that I've come to
any conclusion nothing like that but
it's not inconsequentially dismissed at
least not for me I find that there's
something there or there could be
something there there are people like
Penrose who Nobel Prize when they're
dealing with quantum mechanics
consciousness this is all what I would
say is woo prior I got this sense from
your book and it could be incorrect I
got the sense of a bit of condescension
when the word paranormal was mentioned
or aliens or UFOs and listening to that
thinking okay how was that made with
appeal to Scientific consensus how does
that work when there's already political
biases let alone other biases that maybe
the majority of scientists have so how
do we weight that so that's all what I'm
thinking so please help me through that
what are your thoughts on that yeah I
mean so first of all let's say you know
the quantum theory of Consciousness I
actually think is a totally valid but
real Consciousness I don't think it's um
well I think it's unproven but I think
lots of areas of Consciousness are also
improving so it's like it deserves you
know considerable studying to be taken
seriously
um so I definitely think you know there
are some things that we can dismiss too
easily
um to say with the Paranormal though I
mean that's a tough one because it you
know I have to accept that my own biases
could be kind of shining through that I
mean I would say there have been lots of
good
studies carefully controlled studies uh
trying to detect paranormal phenomena
and I think most scientists even
if they believe in the Paranormal would
have to accept the
um setup of the experiments as being
scientifically valid and um you look at
the outcomes and you look at the
outcomes of multiple experiments through
material analyzes and you find that the
effect size
vanishes to zero which is why
even if I would be so basically to
calibrate my confidence I would never
want to dismiss outer pan something like
a paranormal phenomena
I would never want to say it's
absolutely impossible but I would say
given the evidence that we've got from
all of these
experiments that I think have been well
conducted it's you know maybe not
dismissing the possibility there could
always be another experiment that's
someone's profound like an even better
way of testing for a potential
paranormal phenomena and then maybe that
would show that it does exist and we can
always keep our mind open to that but I
think until that experiment comes along
we have to kind of look at the balance
of the evidence today that's my uh view
of that
um
I don't I think I think like yeah I
think this is where like we need teams
of people to collaborate who come from
lots of different backgrounds and that's
really the best way forward and so you
know maybe with some of the existing
experiments you say oh well that was
done by like a skeptic so they'd set it
up to not be true but what I think you
should do is have like a
pre-registration which is really
fashionable in science now and across a
big collaboration through multiple Labs
you all set up in advance the
experiments that you agree would show
the effect that you want to prove you
gather all the data is all kind of
anonymized it's all analyzed
independently you do you've already
agreed on the statistical analyzes and
then you look at the
you know you you kind of crunch the
numbers you find the results and then
because you've already tried to account
for all of your biases in advance
you have to kind of accept the result
that comes out now that actually was
done with tests of precognition or
paranormal phenomena where you believe
that people can kind of sense the future
and when those
um
uh predetermined studies were conducted
pre-registered studies were conducted
actually found you know they didn't find
the effect uh of that hypothesis they
didn't find that there was a paranormal
phenomena so that's why with that
particular case I would be very
skeptical that there is one because you
know one of the best studies today
didn't find it but I think that's the
kind of collaboration that we need where
you get people of different beliefs
working together by agreeing on a setup
where everyone would be convinced by the
outcome whatever that may be
um and then you you do the experiment
and you you kind of have just have to
accept that like the results that come
out that aren't a result of bias they're
a result of the best science you could
do at that particular time
have you looked into the studies of
Rupert sheldrake or Dean Rayden
uh no I haven't I can't say I have been
like a huge amount of detail um I I
think actually I did look into
sheldropes but I'm afraid I have
forgotten that
um the details of that but yeah
I mean obviously he's a huge name but
you know that I think that's what we
have to accept as well is that we can't
just rely on someone's previous
credentials but we have to be very
specific about the outcomes you know of
the the quality of the evidence itself
independently of who kind of arranged it
and that's why it's important to have
these teams of people who come from lots
of different perspectives to kind of
cancel out each other's biases
potentially what else would be I'm
struggling here to find an issue that's
not climate change that is scientific
that has a huge divide between
conservatives and liberals okay I can
just stick with climate change I'm not a
climate denier nor acceptor like I
mentioned anytime I look into any Theory
I just find flaws and I'm just
completely befuddled and adult and
unassured but anyway the point is that
when it comes to an issue where we make
an appeal to Scientific consensus but
it's a politically charged issue how do
we deal with the political leaning of
the scientists going into it need to be
taken into a account and you need to
somehow re-weight the results I don't
know how to do that and I don't know if
that's the case in climate change and I
don't want to pick a particularly
charged topic like climate change
because like I mentioned I'm just not
interested I'm not trying to cause any
controversy here so I'm trying to find
another one but you get the idea so how
do we deal with that you mentioned that
we need to have teams of people who are
competing against one another from
various backgrounds but in absence of
that what do we do
well I mean I think with climate change
you could have meaningful debates on the
evidence
um
so I mean the problem of climate change
very much like the problem with proving
that cigarette smoke causes cancer is
that it's very difficult to actually do
causal tests of this and I think that
ultimately that is where the controversy
lies it's why people who don't believe
in climate change could always say you
know we're only viewing correlations and
that maybe there's another pact to
driving the rise in temperatures which
is very difficult to denial but some
people do
um similarly with cigarette smoke
tobacco companies
um had always said well we've never you
know we haven't tested done a controlled
trial where you have people without uh
randomly of who you're giving some
cigarette smoke from the age of trendy
you'll and some about they want to take
a set of planets put humans on a set
exactly you can't you couldn't do that
and it was a cause for controversy and
it allowed tobacco Industries to deny
the you know this kind of causal link
that I think we now you'd be very
strange if you denied the link between
smoking and cancer and it's the same
with
um climate change we don't have like a
separate planet where we can set up
a coal or you know Carbon fueled
Industries for centuries to then check
the effects on the climate so you know
that is a big issue and we do have to
look at ways around that now my
impression from looking into the
evidence has been that multiple lines of
evidence from lots of different sources
does all suggest that there is this
strong link between carbon emissions and
climate change and that actually we have
you know with the greenhouse effect we
have a very well understood mechanism
and that there's uncertainty absolutely
we need to acknowledge there's
considerable uncertainty with the
size of the effects that we're going to
see so the models that scientists are
using climate scientists are using a
very honest about you know the best and
the worst case scenarios and there's you
know a difference between them
um but yeah like save from doing that
kind of
absurd experiment I think you know that
is going to be an issue to kind of
result the uh the question and I don't
have an answer for doing that you can't
it does have to be kind of what weight
you give to the different lines of
evidence I think it's can sometimes help
to look at people who have changed
opinion from one side to the other and
to look at the reasons for why they've
done that
um
I think what I've been interested in
psychologically is also how sometimes
you can
what happens when you try to overcome
the look for psychological ways to
overcome that motivated reasoning that
comes from people's initial political
standpoints so things like when you
um
try to cultivate their curiosity or you
create a kind of safe space for them to
talk where they don't have to fear being
judged for their political Viewpoint
um you know what conclusions did they
come to when they look at the evidence
when they've been given those
opportunities
um I think those are some you know those
are the things that we can be doing
um but yeah it's a huge problem and I
think it is one reason that the
intelligence trap is so such a serious
problem to consider is because like you
as an enlightened Society it's really
worrying that you can have such
Divergent views
given the evidence given the same
evidence that people even highly
intelligent Highly Educated people can
come to such polarized viewpoints I
don't have this Solution that's why I'm
interested in the intelligent strap and
how on both sides we can reduce those
biases so we can try to get people to be
looking at the evidence and the most
rational way possible
what is functional stupidity
um that is where companies kind of
create stupidity within the workforce
due to their corporate culture
um
so you know there's lots of reasons for
that one uh potential reason is simply
but people uh simply that you have this
kind of culture of Relentless positivity
and you don't really
allow people to express doubt or
criticism
um so a company might say they only want
Solutions not problems
um that kind of issue and we saw you
know in the book I talk about the
Deepwater Horizon
um
oil spell the Fall Down full of knock
here you know all of these examples
where companies hadn't been allowing
their employees to think critically
about the problems that they were facing
um so that you had this emergent group
thing
um
problems were emerging but no one was
taking notice of them or caring about
them and So eventually uh you had these
disasters that could have been avoided
but each intelligent member of the
workforce was just doing a narrow range
of tasks and they were ignoring all of
the warning signs around them what were
some of the solutions in order to combat
the functional stupidity
uh I mean one is to cultivate within the
workforce
um a culture of disagreement so actually
allowing people to even at the lowest
levels of the corporate hierarchy
allowing them to kind of raise the hand
and to say that they think there's a
problem that's occurring if someone had
done that with deep water Horizon if um
the engineers had said that they saw all
of these anomalies in the processes that
were going on within the rig that could
have been prevented similarly with Nokia
um just to recap you know with Nokia
they were trying to develop a smartphone
but they kept on failing to meet their
deadlines until Apple had come up with
the amazing iPhone that just like swept
them out of the market you know a lot of
the employees were really worried about
what was going on they had lots of ideas
but though I've been listened to
um
they weren't allowed to kind of raise
their problems about their workflow and
so you want to avoid that you want to
give people the opportunity to disgrive
their boss and for them to not be
punished you want those messages to then
go up the hierarchy and to reach the
people at the top the concept of
functional stupidity as well as the
anecdote the ant the antidotes were
developed in the vein of industrial and
organizational psychology so I'm curious
how does one apply this to an individual
mind
um
so I think uh with the intelligence
strap in general you know we have to
first of all
look at our intellectual humility as one
of those
um
elements that were so important for the
measures of uh evidence-based wisdom
that we discussed and on an individual
Viewpoint we have to
feel free to accept when we're wrong
about something or am I uncertain about
something and to not feel so defensive
that we deny that possibility
um we have to cultivate our curiosity so
allowing ourselves to look into those
tangents that Fascinate us or that have
aroused some kind of question that we
want to be answered and rather than just
ignoring that and trying to focus on
just meeting like a productivity goal
actually just pursuing that Curiosity
answering those questions
um we need to try to have an open mind
in other ways too so like I said with
the questions of of analyzing evidence
you know not just like only accepting
the evidence that supports your point of
view but also trying to look at the
evidence that might disregard or
disprove your point of view and then try
to treat it as fairly as you would for
the evidence that supports your argument
you know balancing the two in hand
um
you know I think you obviously do that
very well when you're looking at
something like climate change you know
from what you've said is like your
allowing yourself to be pulled in each
Direction I think that's really
important might not allow you to come up
with a solution to climate change
because the question is so naughty but
in your everyday life you know when
you're dealing with like a professional
situation
um hopefully like you can integrate that
information and that it might help you
to come up with the solution that's more
sophisticated wiser than if you're just
fallen for my side bias and only
selected the information that was uh
supporting your particular point of view
I think my openness my quote-unquote
openness is buttressed by my closeness
so what I mean is that I'm a judgmental
person by nature and if I ever come
across non-judgmentalist because I'm
fighting my tendency constantly I want
to say actually so I want to be that
person that puts it actually so and so
and so and when I'm looking at alternate
viewpoints I'm doing so because I want
to have the ultimate actually so and so
I want to say I don't know some issue
about plastic bottles so I want to see
okay well what's the opponent say so
that I could say to those people who are
pro plastic bottles actually and then
but what do they say to that so I can
say to those people actually my
non-judgmentalness is instigated by my
judgment but that's what I think you
need
open-mindedness in the sense that you're
not drawn purely by your preconceptions
and that you're willing to look into the
broad range of evidence but you also
need to apply critical thinking you know
you have to be analytical about what
you're looking at many have to
synthesize that you know that's I think
that is fundamentally what we mean by
kind of being a skeptic
um and then I think like what's really
important and this comes back to
intellectual humility is that like you
can come to a conclusion and it's
important I think that we don't always
sit on the fence on every issue but you
can moderate your opinions on something
so you can say I believe that this is
the case and you can even put a number
you know you could say I'm like 60
certain you know
that I think that this is where we stand
on climate change to date or whatever
you're looking at on you know plastic
bottles you know and you can adapt to
that you might then come across a new uh
a new study but you know shifts it one
way or the other but I think it really
helps to have that tennis to realize
there's a spectrum of confidence whereas
I think especially with social media
today and identity politics and this
kind of tendency
to get attention of having very strong
views we always think it's like you have
to be 100 one way or a hundred percent
the other and that's a trap you want to
accept that you is sliding scale and you
can move along that scale and but you
don't have to become fixed at one point
does the statement I'm 60 certain about
so-and-so fact the utterance of it make
you then 65 and then the next time you
say it makes you 70 like do you become
entrenched just by saying it even with
an acknowledgment of uncertainty I don't
know I'm asking like unless do you have
to always say 50 percent right in the
middle so that you don't get pulled in
each Direction no because I think
actually
to sit on the fence in that way is also
not
Optimum to be honest and so we note this
from studies of super forecasters and
these are people who have been put
through these huge experiments where
they're asked to predict the outcomes of
different geopolitical events and it
could be you know who wins your revision
to you know who wins the World Cup to
who wins an election to where the war
will break out in a certain region you
know loads of different regions uh loads
of different areas of a political you
know World activity
um and what happens with these uh
uh these tournaments is that the people
are asked to make their predictions and
they cannot update their predictions up
to a certain point and they have to give
their confidence
um and the way it's scored is that
someone who's always just I don't know
is 50 one why it's 50 to something else
but they don't score very well uh
because it's the safe option
um so you're rewarded actually for uh
you know veering one way or the other in
your predictions like what when they
come to actually the final outcome and
they're measuring your performance you
know you're rewarded but if you were
right and you were more confident you
get more points than if you were right
but you showed only a low confidence so
you know it's a complex complicated
measure that they use to do that but you
know essentially that's it the more
confident you are in a right outcome the
better you score and the super
forecasters consistently do perform
better they show more confidence in the
areas where they're right they show
lower much lower confidence in the areas
where they end up being wrong
um
so I think that shows that actually
there is value
in you know
uh expressing
true confidence rather than always
sitting on the fence and actually it is
possible to estimate that you can
actually rationally think you know what
evidence have I looked at
how strongly do I feel that this is true
what what are the potential reasons that
I might be wrong and then you can gauge
you know whether that is more likely or
less likely and that actually is
Meaningful
where I was going with that there are
studies that if you write about some
fact that you don't believe in so let's
say I like Kellogg's cereal you don't
yeah you write about it then all of a
sudden you start to like it more I
believe some people in Wartime use this
they say the Japanese would take in
Americans and say write about why you
like Japan and then all of a sudden they
would when making a statistical Claim
about confidence for instance if I was
to say I think it's 30 likely war will
break out in Canada next year you do so
not by irrational analysis it's
extremely unless you've unless you have
pages and pages and even those pages
will have assumptions
unless you've done some specific
analysis to come to that number you're
using your intuition and you could be
false about your own intuition too so
you could have just come up with a
number so that's why it's saying if you
simply State well if I'm 30 confident
about so and so then you'll become more
entrenched to thinking you're 30 even
though you didn't rationally come up
with a number 30 you didn't analyze that
it's a bit tricky to even give a
confidence level unless it's something
you've studied for years
so you know these people aren't studying
these different issues for years but
they do look at them in depth when
they're doing these super forecasting
tournaments you know
I'm gonna do some some uh strategies
that are kind of
well accepted even by people like Daniel
Carlton napkin calculations yeah so like
look at the base rate
um How likely is it the country of a
similar economy to Canada a similar size
similar history of warfare How likely is
it that that country is going to
enter a war very quickly and then you
know you have a look at the base rate
and you know you might see that it's
like well it happens once in every 10
years once in every 20 years whatever
um you know just coming up with that
base where it actually makes you better
than just going solely with your
intuitions but then these people update
those predictions by looking more
specifically at the different factors
but yeah you know there's no algorithm
that will always give them the right
amount but what this study showed is
that actually they were capable the
super forecasters especially with rating
their confidence much better than chance
much better than just kind of you know
rolling a dice and picking their
confidence based on that
um so they were making the decisions
better than normal handwriting their
confidence better than the average so it
is possible
um I think what you're saying is you
know there's this phenomenon called this
saying is believing effect which is
useful in Psychology and that is true
um but I think like when you're aware of
that possibility you can kind of protect
against it and especially when these
people are trying very hard to think
very analytically about the situation at
hand I think they are protected from
that compared to someone who maybe is
suffering you know undergoing propaganda
in as a prisoner of war or that kind of
situation or someone who's in a more you
know relaxed kind of laboratory
experiment looking at preferences for
cereal who might not actually be trying
to think very carefully about what they
rationally believe in especially like a
preference for cornflakes is going to be
a much more emotional response so much
easier to sway I would say rather than
these super forecasters who are very
deliberately analytically kind of
crunching data trying to come up with
the best analysis that they can do
I see
David can you go over this study I
believe it's a study or maybe it's just
a result about all-star teams not being
as a whole efficient as teams that have
three stars out of ten yeah so I'll use
like an example from soccer you know
um you can kind of rank different
players in soccer according to you know
how they've performed in uh matches such
as the Premier League and then obviously
you know they play for like a team like
Manchester United in the UK or whatever
you know that's separate from them when
they gather together for their countries
teams
um so some players will play for England
some will play for brand some will play
for the US Canada whatever and what you
find there is that you know if you have
those high-ranking players who've had a
really good track record within their
own uh uh sports teams uh football teams
you know within the Premier League you
know if you have too many of those kind
of star players within a country's team
actually you reach a certain threshold
about 70 and it's like diminishing
returns to actually having more and more
star players doesn't help your
performance and may actually damage your
performance so actually you may if you
have a hundred percent of the star
players within your team you might
actually perform worse than a concrete
that only has 50 of kind of of their
team made up of these star players from
the top teams of the world
um now you know why is that well it
seems like it's all related to kind of
the Team Dynamics and the Egos and it
seems that the people who are the really
top performance and it's also true for
basketball it's also true for kind of
investment banking when you have teams
of like top investors who've been
labeled Stars you know then they work
less well with their colleagues and
their company as a whole performs worse
um has all to do with the kind of
rotting egos that they're not
collaborating they're not cooperating in
the best way possible because they're
much more concerned with their own kind
of proving their own performance rather
than
uh you know working for the team and
kind of dissolving within the team to
produce the best overall communal effort
that they can do
and what about with IQ like having a
team dedicated to some intellectual task
a team of let's say 10 is it better to
have people who are all in the 99th
percentile of IQ or is better to have
five of them like how does that work
yeah I mean when it when it comes to IQ
and we called that collective
intelligence where you get the team as a
whole to solve an intellectual problem
um there wasn't the evidence that the uh
too much talent effect no one had looked
at that specifically so I wouldn't rule
it out
um but what they did find is that the
average IQ at the team or the top IQ
said one team had a special and
especially clever person who scored you
know way up the scale neither of those
were great predictors of how the team as
a whole would perform though as a
correlation but it was pretty weak
um
so what proved to be much more important
again was the uh Team Dynamics so kind
of how Equitable the conversation was
between the different people in the team
like were they giving each person the
chance to talk or did you have one
person who thought they were really
smart and were just talking over the
other people
um did you have
uh
you know did you did you have some
people who just weren't really like
picking up on the non-verbal cues as
well measures of emotional sensitivity
so how much people paying attention to
the other people's facial expressions
that actually proved to be a better
prediction of the collective
intelligence than the average IQ of the
people
Steve Jobs had this saying that what he
wants to do or what he does at Apple is
get people who are extremely intelligent
and extremely disagreeable and just put
them all in a room and like rock
tumblers what comes out after are
diamonds does this conflict with that or
it was he mistaken about that or was he
lucky
no I mean I think you know so this is
all about what kind of team Dynamic do
you create and
you could have a case of like you know
like um Kennedy's government during the
Bay of Pigs uh disaster where you have
highly intelligent people but they're
all agreeing with each other and they're
not expressing dissent and you know it
doesn't it doesn't have good outcomes
um
or you could have like a group of people
who are very willing to disagree been a
very amicable constructive way and I
think that's the ideal Dynamic really
where people are absolutely willing to
express uh Discord within the group but
they're also then looking for ways to
to balance those points of view
um not just to kind of combine them all
in this kind of Frankenstein's monster
of different viewpoints which you can
see with some creative tasks you could
be like we're all going to contribute
something and it just becomes a mess but
actually you know really trying to think
very hard about life and being very
honest with each other like does this
work doesn't this work is that rational
is that irrational you know and then
coming to the group decision in that
kind of way with a constructive
discussion and what the research shows
is that actually when you have this kind
of dialogue
um that allows disagreement and allows
constructive uh disagreement than that
actually you know you do get great
outcomes and you get better outcomes
then you could have from any single
individual so they do work then as the
kind of more than the sum of their
components those streams what did you
want to include in the intelligence trap
that you had to exclude because of
whatever reason pacing the editor said
no it's too bloated
uh
not much so there was a section that had
been longer um about a school called the
intellectual but juice Academy
um intellectual virtues Academy that's
right it's in Long Beach and they you
know it's a great school I visited them
they had uh tried to look at all of
these elements of what I would say are
evidence-based wisdom although they
didn't call that but things like
cultivating intellectual humility
amongst the kids curiosity the growth
mindset
um getting them to look at different
perspectives they're done all of these
things and
again with educational outcomes uh it's
really difficult to compare different
schools because you know
it's so tough like to account for the
different backgrounds of the parents and
stuff but those kids were doing really
well academically and they also really
seem to be embracing these different
virtues and so I like to think that
later on when they've gone on to
University and then into later life that
they're going to have they're going to
be more sophisticated thinkers as a
result of their education that have
praised more than just intelligence but
also all of these other traits that I
think are so important for thinking in a
sophisticated and rational way and wise
way you know that will really serve them
well and it was really fascinating look
for me
um uh kind of insight for me of how this
could help to change Education Without
sacrificing the things that we've
appreciated previously like they were
still doing well academically but also
just helping to develop like better
thinkers uh you know more generally
what about for the expectation effect
was there anything that you had to cut
that you oh man I I wish that was
included
no I mean there were just some things
that I didn't think there were there was
enough evidence for
um you know a study showing that
weirdly if you expect to get flu over
the winter you're more likely to get flu
over the winter and that's really
difficult it's really difficult to
explain
um it could just be a difference in well
I say just I think it's equally
fascinating could be a difference in
behavior and that if you are so cautious
about not catching any illness that
actually maybe you're getting less
physical exercise maybe you're actually
exposing yourself less to kind of micros
mod generally to your immune system
isn't performing so well who knows but
yeah definitely that was a result that I
wanted to wait to see when there's more
evidence to kind of replicate that and
then to explore the mechanism
um
that's the main one uh and then how our
expectations can shape personality
change so essentially I have written a
piece for this that should be on this
they should be coming out in the
guardian that looks at whether we have a
kind of mindset of believing that our
personality can develop and grow as we
get older does that actually help people
to change the way they are and the
research shows that it does so people
who have this mindset that they're kind
of malleable people they find it easier
to develop greater reserves of
conscientiousness
um if they are introverts they find it
easier to develop into extra boats and
to overcome shyness you know it's very
important can you expand on that and is
that the same as the growth mindset or
is that different yeah I mean it's very
much related to the growth mindset
actually I would just say it's also the
growth mindset had traditionally been
um
concerned with intelligence but this is
using the similar principle but just
looking at personality like do people
believe that personality is fixed or do
they think that it's malleable that they
believe in the brains plasticity and
ability to change to be see things as um
emotional regulation as something that
you either have or you don't and if
you're angry you cannot possibly calm
yourself down or do you see emotions as
being something that actually are within
your control and that you can you can
change the way you process emotions over
time and all of those you know elements
uh which are all related to the growth
mindset yeah they make a huge difference
for how people develop whether you get
stuck in this rut of behaviors that you
don't find suit your goals or whether
you can actually evolve and adapt have
you looked into studies on yogis and
their expectation effect like that is
what people claim to be able to do under
intense meditation
no I haven't no I would be interested in
that yeah it's a good it would be a
great study if someone were to do it
there's some people like Wim Hof who I
don't know if you know who in the office
yeah I believe he believes that through
his breath technique and I don't think
this entirely mental is he's actually
doing a behavior he believes that he can
repel a virus or viruses of a certain
sort and he can train people and you can
get a study where you impose this
intervention on a set and then have a
neutral other set have you looked into
those claims at all
I haven't I mean
I'd be super fascinated I wouldn't so
like to talk about calibrating my
confidence I would say I would be kind
of 50 50 on that at the moment not
knowing the details but you know we do
know that the mind is connected to the
immune system
um and that brings up meditation can
influence
your the active to your immune system
and especially if you have chronic
inflammation
um which can be caused by kind of
anxiety you know and can be affected by
your breathing as well that that can
then throw your immune system out of
balancing a more susceptible to certain
illnesses so it doesn't sound like
implausible to me but I just I would be
interested to see that
in a you know reasonably sized study to
look at that the difference between the
two groups you know yeah it's
fascinating this is potentially an ill
no this is an ill-defined question I'm
sure it's one you thought about how far
can the placebo effect slash the
expectation effect be taken because some
people through meditation which I'm
synonymous with an expectation effect
can boil water or at least can raise the
temperature of their body drastically
and it's something that you thought was
only a part of the autonomic nervous
system like you cannot control that yeah
and then there are other cases like you
mentioned of not as quote-unquote
trivial as pain even though pain is not
true it's something that we would think
okay yeah you can coerce yourself into
pain you can take yourself out of it
mentally how far can it be taken the
placebo and expectation effect
okay I mean I can play we have to be
really careful in
defining the limits of what the science
shows that it can do and you know I do
think it is limited in what it can
achieve
um I don't think that by changing your
expectations you can shrink a tumor for
example you know and I think there have
been studies that try to look at things
that optimism amongst cancer patients
and you know I don't think you see a
strong effect from that and
I actually think there's a danger with
over claiming that people are only going
to be disappointed or that they might
even start to blame themselves you know
if they are not getting better from some
illness like um you know right so they
think it's because they're not being
positive enough that only adds to the
stress and makes them you know makes a
bad situation even more terrible so
that's why I think like I've cried
really carefully to look at like I said
like the effects that I think are
supported by like a substantial number
of studies
um
you know so your book is like the
scientific version of The Secret yeah
that's exactly how I want it but yeah
and it's like you know but also I think
just because it can't perform what I
would say are Miracles you know like
curing cancer it doesn't mean that it's
not really significant and that it
doesn't have a really profound effect on
our life and actually we know that say
your beliefs about aging do seem to
predict your longevity
um but that's not through some kind of
unknown mechanism that's actually pretty
very well established mechanisms and
essentially if you associate aging with
uh decline in disability and all of
these things well that makes you less
active so there's a behavioral component
there's also like increases your stress
you know over months and then years
because if you think as you're getting
older but your life is kind of Gonna
Fall to Pieces right that makes all of
the challenges you've placed more
stressful it raises cortisol levels so
that they're chronically High erases
inflammation that causes biological
damage and then that predisposes you to
illness and then we know that that can
change uh gene expression within the
cells so you start to have the
biological clock as it's known kind of
ticking at a faster rate all that's very
well documented I said that's incredible
and actually according to one
longitudinal study the difference
between people with the positive and the
negative use of Aging the positive view
would be that you see aging as a time a
kind of Greater wisdom you know new
possibilities the difference between
those two mindsets actually was about
seven and a half years in
lifespan so it's you know really
profound but I'm not quality of life
increased as well or no just yeah
exactly quality of life you know let's
just say Best of Both Worlds great great
susceptible to alzheimer's
cardiovascular disease to all of these
things
um but it's like but I don't find any of
those mechanisms miraculous actually I
just think it's it's what we know we
know about how the mind can affect
behavioral we know how the mind can
affect stress and stress can affect
illness it's just linking them all
together and showing that something that
you you might
but not think to be that important
actually over time over decades adds up
and really makes a difference
yeah that's remarkable do you imagine
that if you were to intervene in
someone's life if you were to impart in
them a set of beliefs that that would
increase their not only quality of life
but their lifespan and if so what are
those beliefs like if you were to
prescribe it with all the disclaimers
that come along with that yeah exactly I
mean no one has performed because
ideally you would have like a 40-year
study where you'd change people's
beliefs and you kept on coming back to
them you know the research hasn't been
around long enough to do that but there
are short-term studies where you kind of
give people like an exercise program and
then some of these people are also given
uh psychological supports alongside the
exercise program so they might be
encouraged to kind of think about their
bodies in a different way to kind of
embrace the fact that as they're
exercising that they're actually
outperforming people of a similar age to
themselves you know so you falsify the
data to tell them this or you just yeah
um yeah I can't remember to be honest it
might have been falsified in one study I
think in others you're just kind of
feeding them this positive information
that you know your health is within your
control and as you age that you can you
can actually like um benefit from
exercise and you know that there are
these other opportunities no matter how
old you are
um and what you find is that when you
change the mindset in those ways but um
whether it's through deception or
whether it's just through kind of
positive encouragement that you seek
greater benefits for those people so
that's you know it's only over a couple
of months but like you do get this
signal that changing the mindset really
is being beneficial there's another
study that had looked at giving people
subliminal uh signals through kind of
compute again they were playing these
were old people and they found that
actually giving them subliminal signals
to give them positive associations with
aging but that again was associated with
an improvement in their health from
actually the size of those improvements
were equivalent to doing a proper
exercise program so really quite
significant
what does this say about the
relationship of Consciousness to reality
the fact that if we believe so and so it
increases the chances of so and so
believe which is an aspect of
Consciousness increases the tens of so
and so in a external reality if there is
external because there's some people who
are idealists and so on
right exactly so
you know I don't to be honest I'm
fascinated by all kinds of theories of
Consciousness and the idea that we're
living in a simulation and all of that I
don't think this research tells us
anything about that
um but I do think on a more superficial
kind of level not as profound as what is
the nature of reality but like you know
this is essentially what we're showing
is that our thought processes are
changing
our reality in the future and again
that's through just very I wouldn't say
mundane but very well accepted
behavioral perceptual and physiological
mechanisms that we know happen day to
day hour to hour and all this is showing
is that actually sometimes the effects
can you know add up and be really
profound
um you know I I always like to say
actually like we know that our mindset
can shape our bodies like all the time
if you think of your favorite food your
mouth starts celebrating it's producing
enzymes to help you to
digest that food you know that is an
example of an expectation effect
um if you feel nervous you start to get
cramps in your stomach that's an example
of your brain evading your digestive
system this the expectation effect is
just showing that actually you know
those might seem tribulous like trivial
examples but actually there are lots of
ways that we haven't acknowledged or
um put to use previously that we can
harness to improve our wellness and our
health and even our longevity and that
now we have that knowledge there are
very specific techniques you can use to
to really make the most of the mind-body
connection have you looked into the
subject of ego depletion yes so I mean
that's fascinating
um again like an area where you had like
a huge body of research and then like
there seems to be some contradictory
evidence but essentially are you
referring to the replication crisis
because I don't know if that okay but
then one reason that they might not be
replicable these studies is the fact
that actually mindset plays a role in
ego depletion so if you expect to be
depleted you become more depleted if you
think that your willpower is kind of
unlimited and that actually the more you
practice your willpower the more you can
get into that zone when you're doing
those difficult problems if you believe
that then actually that becomes your
reality and you find that your
concentration kind of uh you know
actually grows as you focus on the task
ahead so yeah you know
uh how where we stand on ego depletion
in general like I wouldn't like to say
but absolutely mindsets are having an
effect there in some way or another
before we start to wrap I want you to
explain what the pilot site test is and
then why is it important
okay I mean this was
um
study from a few years ago I'd say when
the research on the expectation effect
was really starting to expand beyond the
placebo of fatal medicine and it was
just looking at how people's vision is
affected by their expectations
um now I've mentioned throughout the
conversation
that one of the pathways that the
expectation effect can influence us is
through perception
um we know this from all kinds of
studies you know the taste of food
depends on what you expect the food to
taste like if you the same chemical that
causes parmesan to smell so delicious
it's actually also behind the smell of
vomit but our conscious experience is
very different depending on which we
believe that we're smelling
um
it just seems that this also happens
with vision and with the clarity of
vision so this study by Ellen Langer at
Harvard University seemed to suggest
that if you
lead people to believe that their vision
is going to be more acute
than it really is
then that can actually help them to see
more clearly and just seems to be that
the we know the brain does a lot of work
in tidying up our vision
um the stuff that hits our retinas those
patterns are not what we consciously
experience because there's so much
processing going on in the brain and it
seems that actually
this when you she kind of primed people
to believe that they were going to have
better Vision by putting them in a
flight simulator and telling them that
they were kind of
uh acting as expert Pilots or that she
gave them exercises that led them to
believe that their eyesight was going to
improve or she turned the site test
upside down so that the smaller letters
were at the top and people have this
Association that they can read the first
line on the site chart you know in all
of these cases multiple experiments
people's Vision did seem to improve
compared to the control groups who
aren't given the same kind of priming to
to believe that their site was gonna be
better than than it was
um now you know I'm really careful in my
book to say this isn't uh an excuse to
kind of throw away your glasses you know
these were kind of short-term
experiments
um but I do think it's still quite
profound that like
what we're
that something as basic as kind of
eyesight can insult to a certain extent
be influenced by our beliefs and
actually there's independent research
showing that you know like if you if
you're a bit short-sighted and you see a
road sign but you know what it's going
to say will you actually see that sign
more clearly than if it was an
unfamiliar sign where you don't know
what the letters are going to read so
actually it fits with multiple studies
it's not just Ellen Langer's research
that shows that
um
expectations can shape visual perception
it was just one study though that I
found especially fascinating see I'm
wondering now if there's a connection
between this and something we talked
about from your earlier book I asked is
there an association between arrogance
and intelligence he said not exactly at
least that hasn't been studied but there
is an association with people who are
intelligent then believing that they are
less susceptible to cognitive biases and
I'm wondering now if priming for visual
Acuity if you tell someone hey you you
have great vision then all of a sudden
you can see a bit better if that's the
case then maybe it's not intelligence
breeds arrogance but arrogance breeds
intelligence because you're like hey I
believe I'm much more intelligent and
then so I become a bit more intelligent
now maybe I'm taking it a bit too far
but is there an association there is it
like an increase of five IQ points ten
IQ points can't say that
well like um so you know there have been
all of these apps looking at kind of
brain training and they've been again
contradictory evidence but some really
seem to show that people do these kinds
of games then they improve their IQ
scores
um but what scientists at around 2015
realized was that way but these
participants were recruited kind of
primed them to expect that they were
gonna see those improvements you know
the adverts were often like
um you know want to help with a test of
brain enhancement you know
um control interesting like this room
um and they looked they analyzed that
data those historic studies and they
showed that those with the kind of
posters that had primed the expectation
of improved intelligence did see greater
gains because of the
um associated with the brain training
compared to those who haven't
um they then did their own independence
study which showed exactly what they'd
predicted that actually if you tell
people but by doing these tasks they're
going to get smarter they improve their
performance by about five IQ points so
it did seem to suggest that there is a
benefit to that and actually it's been
replicated just earlier this um well uh
last year at the end of last year a
similar study
um so I do think like having that
self-belief can be really valuable but
in my opinion like we don't want to
develop overconfidence because that is
also associated with greater
susceptibility to numerous biases
it might help your IQ it might also ban
damage your reasoning and decision
making but I think what's important
there is still to kind of recognize this
Your Capacity to grow and improve and it
comes back to what we were talking about
with how we can boost our learning if
you see frustration as being inherent in
your intellectual growth that will make
your intellectual growth more likely and
I think it's you know very much the same
phenomena now taking this back to how
far can we push this I know that's a
dangerous question it sounds like we
have untapped potential now what that is
in terms of a percentage well it may
vary from task to task if you can even
place a number on it now there is a
phenomenon called induced savantism
acquired savantism you don't induce it
it's just called the acquired someone
for people who don't know there are some
people called savants who they seem
to be not up to par intellectually in
most tasks except one where they're
extremely versed extremely well so like
they could read at a rate five times the
ordinary person or they can play music
just from hearing a song once or
recreate a scene from seeing it in like
a second then there are some people who
through some neurological defect that
occurs later in life they were Ordinary
People and they're even ordinary quote
unquote afterward
but after the trauma they have acquired
some ability that ordinarily is
associated only with savants and it
seems like most of our neurological
activity is inhibitory strangely enough
we would think that hey that we have
this whole prefrontal cortex is doing
all these calculations and producing
content it's stymying most of what's
occurring so it's like stopping some
reflexes well anyway I was just
wondering if you have come across a
relationship between the expectation
effect and acquired savantism
I have a remarkable abilities in general
so I'd have to say
I'm not 100 familiar with the research
on acquired cervantism too because I'd
heard I'm not sure if it's true with
some of the people who show
amazing creativity well they show
amazing kind of productivity with their
creativity but whatever it's actually
independently rated as being original
and Innovative and fantastic you know in
the same way but say the
um innate uh savants are you know that I
think I'd heard that was another matter
that maybe they they're not inhibited
and that they really you know have it
feel compelled to create but whether
it's actually of a high quality
according to other people's stunts it's
an upper question but I do think there
is this kind of you know even just
creating is something that we hold
ourselves back from like lots of people
have creative anxiety where we're so
worried about expressing ourselves that
we just don't do it so we find
brainstorming really
excruciating we feel we put limits on
you know our own idea generation I do
think that actually the expectation
effect is really relevant in that case
uh it might not make you I mean
immediately have the creativity of
Leonardo da Vinci but I think if you
have this ability this belief that your
creative efforts are valued and that
actually it's an incremental process you
recognize that your first idea might not
be your best idea but then you might
iteratively improve your ideas over time
I think that's the kind of belief that
will have an impact on your overall
quality of your create about over time
if you see it as something that can be
nurtured and you recognize that you you
don't have to limit yourself but you can
actually give free reign to your
creativity and then refine it I think
that's what you really want to aim for
so David what's your next book on and
what are you looking forward to this
year yeah so well I'm looking forward to
writing this book which is all about
um social connection I'll save that so
I'm super excited about that um and then
just you know other elements of my life
like I've been learning Italian for like
a few years and I'm gonna
um only go to ifley to spend like a
month or so there but I'm really great
to kind of gain the chance to kind of
immerse myself in that culture
um yeah those are the main things and
then just looking forward to my
journalism like I love just love coming
up with new ideas researching learning
new new stuff and then finding the best
way to present it and I'm continuing to
look that how did you learn Italian was
it through an app or
no it was pretty very boring an old
person through like evening classes and
then
um I've got Italian friends that I kind
of speak to really regularly now so it's
just constant practice and constant
um you know reading Italian stuff
listening to podcasts just you know very
boring just kind of putting in the work
yeah did you start to learn Italian
because you heard the research about if
you know another language you're more
open or you're more rational I remember
this was in the expectation effect I'm
not sure yeah it did influence me a bit
but it's also just I'm super interested
in Italian culture and the language and
the literature like so you know it's a
combination really it's just that
feeling you want to be able to
communicate with another group of people
and to see the world from their
perspective I think that's what's always
fascinated me great which place in Italy
are you looking forward to going uh Rome
great great you've never been uh I've
been on holiday but I'm just looking
forward to kind of I think the longer
you spend in a place like more you know
familiar you become more about the kind
of deeper you can understand it so yeah
great great well
man it's it's a pleasure thank you so
much for spending almost three hours
with me if not three hours
I appreciate it yeah my pleasure thanks
for such interesting questions
all right you just watched the episode
with David Robson thank you so much and
on the last point about people being
afraid to create I find that to be the
case people just need a push and so
earlier this year or earlier last year
we had this physics and Consciousness
explication contest where people who are
just on the verge of producing content
but needed a bit of a nudge we tried to
give him that at least modicum of an
incentive so the pace one the physics
and Consciousness explication contest
the winners are announced either now or
they're going to be announced and you
can look out for a video on that there
are several wonderful wonderful videos
that came from this contest this
Expedition this exploratory effort that
we engaged in together it's fascinating
it's unbelievable if you'd like to
contribute to theories of everything
then visit patreon.com Kurt jymungal
each dollar helps your support is what
allows there to be a full-time editor
who's editing this right now allows
there to be an operations manager who
manages my well who does virtually
everything around here and constantly
manages my disquietude and my
fretfulness and my stress and the fact
that I'm unnerved because there's so
much to do he relieves that he takes
many plates away from me so that's great
you're allowing that support so that we
can put out even higher quality podcasts
with even higher frequency thank you so
much the podcast is now concluded thank
you for watching if you haven't
subscribed or clicked on that like
button now would be a great time to do
so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
also I recently found out that external
links count plenty toward the algorithm
which means that when you share on
Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you